I believe there is definitely a pressure
to pursue your purpose and I think
sometimes the pressure to find your
purpose actually paralyzes you in the
process and in the pursuit and so I
think when we are guiding people who are
talking about purpose we have to have
very thoughtful and mindful
conversations around it now if someone
comes up to me and says Jay I don't know
what my purpose is can you help me as
you just put there I would focus on the
definition of purpose that comes from
the Sanskrit term Dharma in my first
book think like a monk I talk about this
concept of Dharma which has many
different definitions but one of my
favorite definitions that it has is
eternal purpose or Eternal Duty it means
something that you're naturally inclined
to do something you have proclivities
and propensities for and I think both
you and I love the Japanese ikigai the
reason for being why we live and Dharma
and ikigai have a lot in common hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need it I need it for me
because I I don't wake up every day and
say yes let's go conquer the world now I
wake up and and I need that external
motivation to match my internal
motivation when I see somebody who's
doing amazing things it makes me just
want to play a bigger game and so I hope
that today's video makes you want to
play a bigger game too because your
message matters and let's get it out to
the world so today let's get some
incredible wisdom from the one and only
Jay Shetty enjoy
and so I always tell people look purpose
is this big scary word that needs to be
simplified and so my first
simplification is
let's see if we can discover four things
the first is what you're passionate
about what you're really interested in
and if you're like Jay I don't know what
I'm passionate about I don't know what
I'm interested in we go to the root and
we say well what are you curious about
what is it that you think intrigues you
even if you're not passionate about it
yet if that's a strong word the second
thing I'd say is what are you naturally
good at what do you already have
expertise or skills in that you aren't
even aware of or you're not even
conscious of so many of us have so many
talents so many hidden gifts but we keep
placing them on the back burner the
third thing I'd ask is is there a pain
in the world that you want to solve is
there a problem in the world that you
feel really called to you some people
don't find their purpose through their
passion they find it through their pain
they find it through a stress they want
to alleviate in the world a challenge
they want to remove from the world and
then the fourth and final one is as
ikigai says is uh can I get paid for it
and that's a that's a that's a fourth
and final consideration because I don't
think purpose has to be something you
have to get paid for it can be something
we dedicate our weekends our evenings
our vacations too as well and so the way
I Define it is that your passion makes
you happy and when you use your passion
in the service of others that's a
purpose because it makes them happy so
how can you use your gifts and your
talents and the things you love to
improve the lives of others that's what
purpose really is and now we're not
looking at it as this big word we're
actually looking at it as this broken up
equation of what am I passionate about
what am I excelling at what problem do I
want to solve and then if I can how can
I get paid for it where do you begin
when it comes to building this new skill
around how you think about love where
would you tell somebody is it rule
number one
it is rule number one in the book but I
think you've just brought out a
beautiful point that I want to respond
to
and it's that we all have a story that
we're writing about love
and the interesting thing is that our
mind makes us fiction writers and we're
writing our own fictional version of
what our love story looks like and
it changes every single day one day we
feel like anyone would be lucky to have
us but then there's months that go by
when we feel we're completely unlovable
and we're not enough
and I think it's really interesting
because we both know this that the story
you're saying to yourself the story
you're telling yourself naturally
becomes your reality because you're
looking for the facts you're looking for
those truths in your life so if you
think to yourself
you know no one's attracted to me right
now you are now going around looking for
how many people are not attracted to you
and don't look at you it's almost like
when you make a decision to say I'm
thinking about buying this brand of car
or I'm thinking about buying this brand
of whatever it may be now you see that
brand everywhere you hear it everywhere
right it's not that suddenly everyone
just started buying that car on the
streets or buying that product or brand
but you see it everywhere because it's
at the Forefront of your Consciousness
and so if the story is I'm not good
enough I'm not ready and I'm unlovable
which is a very true and real story of
the people that are riding in for us
that unfortunately is what you're going
to perpetuate and that's why rule one is
about what you do alone because if
you're waiting for someone to love you
to believe you're lovable
that means you're saying that the day
they change their mind you're now
immediately unlovable and so you're
deciding whether you're lovable or not
based on whether someone else thinks
you're worthy of love
and I think that that sets us up for a
lot of pain a lot of stress a lot of
pressure most of us don't realize that
we get consumed by fear instead of using
fear so fear becomes our being in the
sense that fear becomes what controls us
it tells us what we should do and what
we shouldn't do it tells us how we
should think and we shouldn't think it
stops us from doing stuff that's really
important to us and it makes us do
things that we would never ever do it
makes us say things to people that we
love that we would never want to say to
them and on the other end it stops you
from saying things you really want to
say to someone because you don't want to
appear weak and your ego won't let you
Sophia takes this really magnetic
controlling effect on our whole lives
but fear at the same time can be one of
the healthiest things because it's
basically giving you a signal
to what's important it's basically
giving us a signal as to how you feel
and when you use it as a signal not as a
suggestion or a push it changes
everything so let's let's make that
practical when you are in your home and
if the fire alarm goes off that gives
you a signal to say check for the fire
check if there's a fire right now if you
go oh just turn it off it doesn't matter
let's let's avoid my fear let's avoid it
let's just turn it off let's forget
about it your house could burn down or
if you're lucky there was nothing and
it's fine but the odds are that there
could be a fire
now if you're someone who goes well let
me inspect it let me be curious about
that I am scared that there's a fire in
my house now that I've heard the fire
alarm but let me be curious let me
inspect let me check
imagine we approached our fear in that
way imagine every time I felt scared of
something I said well let me get curious
about this why am I scared of this why
is it affecting me so much what about
this scares me is it all of it or is it
just a part of it when you start doing
it you start to break that fear down and
that's the healthy way of looking at
fear rather than the unhealthy way of
saying forget about it keep it away from
me I don't want to go there and so for
me I really feel that
fear is what blocks us from these
beautiful breakthroughs in life and it
has such a Chokehold on us like it's
such a strong hold on us and I think
most of us are living Our Lives because
we're scared of what someone will say
what someone will think or what someone
will do
and that feels like something that we're
going to regret when we're at the end of
our Lives I have a check-in for every
day
every month every quarter and every year
with your partner there's one question
per item so one check-in every day one
check-in every month one check in every
quarter and one check in every year
every day checking with your partner
and ask them
what did you do for yourself today
beautiful just checking with them
because I promise you they've been
trying to do everything for you the kids
their family but they didn't do anything
for themselves chicken what did you do
for yourself every day every month check
in with them and ask them
what can I help you with what can I be a
part of what can I support you with
because over that month they may be
going through so many different things
now you get a chance every quarter this
is one that I do with rather every
quarter it's uncomfortable but it's
needed I ask you this question
I should ask her three questions
is this relationship going in the
direction you want
[Music]
um
if it is what's going right what should
we do more of
if it is then what are we both willing
to do about it so what's that Collective
responsibility and then once a year
what are your goals what are you trying
to achieve this year so those four
check-ins yes so simple every day every
month every quarter every year yeah you
will always be in touch with the
heartbeat of your partner in the pulse
of where they're at also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there we're always trying to create the
same past yes as opposed to a new future
future and I find that what's really
interesting about their oldest studies
show that Nostalgia makes us believe
that the past was more phenomenal than
it actually was if you remember that
party you went to a college it's better
in your memory than it actually was if
you actually could have gone back and
remembered how you felt hungover and
what you broke a bone or whatever
happened but now in your memory it's
beautiful beautiful right so our memory
also is slightly warped of the past no
questions you can make things feel much
better or much worse sometimes no
question but what's what's really coming
out for me right now is this idea that
it's it's something you said a couple of
moments ago and and it sparked a thought
for me I remembered a story that Vanessa
Bryan told about Kobe Bryant after he
passed away
I was fortunate enough to interview him
around three months before it before his
tragic passing
and she told this story and she said
that Kobe would play through every
injury he would play through every pain
he would play through everything even in
the doctors and his coaches would say
stop playing
and she asked him she said once why he
still plays right again going back to
our curiosity yes not assuming you know
your partner she asked him why do you
still play and this is just her and him
there's no cameras there's no she's
telling this story but at the time it
was just them too
he said it's because there's someone
who's paid for a ticket today they saved
up and this is the only time they're
ever going to be able to come maybe a
son's maybe a dad's brought his kid
maybe someone's come to the game they're
a lifelong fan and they came today and
today is the only day they're gonna get
to see me and if I say I'm injured
they won't get to see me so I'm gonna
play so that that person one person gets
to see me play and then he goes and wins
yes and it's like that's love we live in
a perception of a perception of
ourselves if I think you think I'm smart
I feel smart
and if I think you think I'm stupid I
feel stupid and so we're basing our
self-worth on a perception of a
perception do you know how messed up
that is it's like not only is it someone
else's subjective opinion that you don't
even know so you're being subjective
about someone's subjectivity and that's
what we all experience on a daily basis
we've forgotten our reality
because we're lost within a perception
within a perception within a perception
within a perception if there's one habit
that I have every single day it's
refining my intention because your
intention is the easiest thing to lose
you know how would your friends describe
you in three words my question is how
would you describe yourself in three
words you know it's it's always been
about how other people view us and when
life is lived through how other people
view us we make decisions based on how
we think other people will view us when
we start something new and we try
something new our ego convinces us that
what we believe in and what we're
fighting for is the right answer not
realizing that everyone could be wanting
the same thing
they're coming from a different angle
and a different priority set
and so we can have the most impact when
we recognize the uniqueness of
everyone's priority set
and we can have the most impact when we
focus on our own and invest in our own
how many of you have ever found yourself
in a random rabbit hole on social media
right you you start off watching a
friend then you end up on a cat video a
dog video and then somehow you're
watching a video on Justin Bieber's mom
then it just kind of goes on and on and
on there's this incredible study that I
love quoting at the moment when men and
women were asked to be alone with their
thoughts for 15 minutes
or choose an electric shock
sixty percent
sixty percent of men chose an electric
shock
and thirty percent of women chose an
electric shock so you do want to be
alone with our thoughts for 15 minutes
so social media has just provided us a
way to fill that 15 minutes
it's us who are so uncomfortable being
alone how many of you pull out your
phones and then
put it back inside your pocket and then
wonder why you pulled it out in the
first place anyone else do that I do
that all the time and then you you
convince yourself that you looked at the
time but then when you ask yourself what
the time was you don't know what it is
you know we take all our funds out of
pocket 200 times a day and check check
all our posts two thousand times a day
plus on average for me it comes down to
a place of personal discipline
capitalism means you're going to be hit
by multiple messages forever before
social media it was the Billboards
before the Billboards it was something
else I wasn't alive but the point the
point is that there's always been a way
in which consumerism and capitalism will
constantly trying to bombard you so we
can either sit here and complain about
it or be upset about it but guess what
social media is not going away there's a
beautiful thought from Martin Luther
King that I always think of when when I
answer and thinking of a question like
this and he says that those who love
peace need to learn to organize
themselves as well as those who love war
those who are coming from a place of
love compassion and empathy rely so much
on just love compassion and empathy we
don't get strategic we don't get focused
we don't Hustle Hard we don't work and
that was the difference commitment that
I decided to make my own life I was like
if I'm going to be an ambassador for
change if I'm going to make wisdom go
viral if my videos are going to be the
most seen videos on social media which
they are I'm gonna have to work as hard
as someone who wants to break the world
how many of you feel like the months are
just passing by and it's crazy to
believe there were over a quarter of the
way through the year
but this is what happens when we don't
have really clear goals targets and
tasks this approach has really helped me
manage my time better I have big monthly
goals I have four weekly targets and I
have one daily task the one daily task
is the baby step towards the weekly
Target and the weekly Target added up
all four of them leads to the big
monthly goal so what you're doing here
in essence is breaking down something
that feels quite unachievable impossible
to do and quite challenging into small
manageable chunks sometimes you can be
sitting there thinking wow I don't know
how I'm going to get that done by the
end of this month if you've ever felt
that way use this model first come up
with how can you break that Big Goal
down into four separate tasks once you
have these four weekly targets now all
you need to do is divide each weekly
Target into a daily task so basically
you end up working on something daily
that you achieve weekly which helps you
achieve something monthly now you've
completely deconstructed this impossible
unachievable idea into something very
simple and manageable I remember after I
had my first viral video I didn't want
to make any videos really because
because you're scared of success like
you're scared of but weren't you excited
you're like oh 50 million views like a
lot of people you get well that's the
point right like it at one point it has
to become about more than the success or
failure and that's where the meaningful
Mission it comes back to that right it
always comes back to that and I was
talking about this with our friend and
we talked about you too it's so funny I
was talking to Stephen Butler recently
because I was in London and we talked
about you too because we're talking
about relationships and
he was saying what he'd learned from you
and the conversations you guys have had
and and now I'm talking about him to you
but he I was I was talking to him about
the idea of just like getting
comfortable with the idea that at one
point we all have to embrace
insignificance and irrelevance
in a public sense but that in an
internal sense the meaningful mission
was what was carrying you yes so if you
stop because people stop following or if
you start only when people are following
then there isn't a meaningful Mission
because the meaningful mission is what
you were doing whether people were
following or not because it's what you
wanted to do and who you wanted to be
and so I think it comes back to that
that if you only play when you're
winning and you stop when you're losing
or you don't pivot and learn a new way
to serve then there isn't a meaningful
Mission at the Bedrock of it and so I
loved that the meaningful mission is at
the heart of everything
because there will always be changes
like your the platforms will change the
algorithms will change people will come
and go people will come and go and you
see the people that have lasted the test
of time it's usually people who have a
meaningful Mission it's just saying you
want to keep serving keep giving they
feel they have that rule number two was
take a look in the karma mirror and you
started to write off because the word
Karma we have this association with it
but there's a misconception about what
it really means yeah I think that we
have a very limited understanding of a
lot of Eastern Concepts and Eastern
words and I was very fortunate having
lived as a monk for three years I spent
a lot of time studying The Vedas and
spiritual literatures that give insight
and depth to these Concepts and words
that we now hear like we hear Kismet or
Karma or all these words are thrown
around in the western world but we don't
necessarily have the most thorough
understanding of the word and so karma
is often you know what goes around comes
around I think there's that great Justin
Timberlake song right like it's like and
it's like whatever you do you get it
back there's some truth in that but
that's not fully what it is so karma is
this cycle of Impressions forming into
ideas forming into patterns in our life
so let me break down what I mean by that
when you make a choice in your life
that choice has a certain reaction or a
certain consequence and that consequence
is there to teach you about whether you
choose to do that again so let's use
that for health when I see a fried
burger with a bunch of fries with a
sugary drink right there in the evening
and I get attracted to that and I'm like
that's what I want to eat tonight I make
that choice in the moment it feels
amazing but then the next morning I
don't feel as good that consequence is
not I got what I give out that
consequence was for me to reflect on do
you want to eat that again next time
when you have that choice is that's what
you're going to choose and so I feel
like that's what Karma's trying to do so
sometimes you make a choice
and we don't look at how we make choices
we focus far more on the result
so let's think about this how many times
have you ever dated someone
later on to realize that they were the
wrong person
but you never went back to think about
how you made the decision to be with
them you were just really upset that
they were the wrong person and they hurt
you or whatever they did but what if you
went back and said oh actually I chose
to be with them because they were
controlling and that made me feel safe
oh wait a minute I chose to be with them
because they kind of took care of
everything and fixed all my problems so
I thought that they knew what they were
doing oh wait a minute I chose to be
with them because I was in a weak place
and therefore they made me feel a sense
of safety and certainty and I let them
do that oh now next time I make a
decision to be with someone let me make
sure that I'm not basing it on that
criteria let me actually go in as an
equal so that's what karma is trying to
get you to have that reflection my
greatest skill is knowing that I can
learn something if I want to and if I
apply myself to it
and I really deeply care about it that I
will find a way to get really good at it
and I don't think you can separate that
from Impact because impact means there's
a beautiful quote by Bruce Lee where he
said that I'm not scared of the person
that has practiced 10 000 kicks one time
each I'm scared of the person who's
practiced one kick ten thousand times
and that's the switch that we have to
make is that are we willing to practice
this one kick this one move ten thousand
times or whatever it may be and that to
me is the Difference Maker so I would
say that there's a lot of strategy
because now it all makes sense like
social media meditation oh that fits it
didn't make sense when I was collecting
those skills and so as Steve Jobs says
you can only connect the dots uh looking
backwards you can't moving forwards to
me when I was collecting I was just like
I love people and I love connecting with
lots of people so social media would be
useful maybe that's literally all I had
as a tool it wasn't like oh I'm gonna
learn this then I'm gonna learn this and
then we're gonna it wasn't that thought
through and at the same time when I
became a monk it wasn't like oh one day
I'm gonna write a book about being it
wasn't that it was hey I think this is
what my calling is so it was a naive
innocent following of what I'm being
called to do at the time
then matched with what do we do with
this now that we have it as a skill and
taking a risk based on that so I would
say it's
it's I don't know what you call that
whether it's discipline how in the world
is someone with no comp or low
confidence or low self-esteem struggling
from an ego issue and I don't know that
I articulated it well enough although
it's in one of the podcasts that I've
released one of my solo podcasts but you
articulate it right on so talk about
that for a second yeah so it's a it's an
interesting concept and it's talked
about the bhagavad-gita another Monk
text and and in the book it talks about
how like ego is demonstrated in two ways
so ego is either I am the best in the
world and I think I'm better than
everyone or ego says you're the worst in
the world you're the worst than everyone
you're you're much worse than everyone
or you say my life is the best and the
greatest my life is the worst right my
life is far worse than anyone else so
the ego likes to push you to the extreme
it doesn't like to give you balance and
honesty and reality it likes to it wants
to make you feel like you've got the
worst life in the world and no one else
understands it no one gets there only
you get in you get the worst or you're
the best and no one else gets you you're
untouchable
and people miss that they're like how
does that make sense exactly like you
said but it does make sense because the
ego wants to be the top or the bottom
but the top of the bottom yeah it
doesn't just want to be at the bottom of
the bottom yeah it's going to be the
bottom of the bottom of the bottom but
the top of the bottom right well set
yeah and so we get lost in that and we
don't think of it as eager and that's
why the only antidote to either ego is
self-honesty is being honest and honesty
is I'm good at these things I'm great at
these things and I suck at these things
right like that's honest yeah like and
we could all sit down me and you could
sit down with a list of our skills and
map out what we were great at what we
were average at and what we knew we were
terrible at yes and that's honestly that
keeps you so away from either ego the
the challenge with all self-centeredness
is that all you then indulge yourself in
is your own pain well there you go right
you just indulge you just submerge and
like immerse yourself in pain because
it's all about you yeah and you know I
think Gandhi said it best is that you
find yourself when you lose yourself in
the service of others
and what I love about that statement is
that what he means by that is and and
empaths get this mixed up sometimes so I
want to clarify because a lot of people
who are empaths are listening like Jay
I'm always trying to help people but
then I get screwed over so here's here's
the answer you're not helping people so
that they can thank you you're not
helping people so that they can be
grateful to you you're helping people
because you know it's the right thing to
do but more importantly you're helping
people because you get to understand
that experiment and experience
different parts of yourself when I
helped kids growing up in India that
were they didn't have food and we were
giving them free food I learned so much
about myself when I was able to go and
give talks that help people or now I
make videos or podcasts you learn more
about yourself when you help people you
don't learn anything about yourself when
you're just sitting there filling out a
quiz going who am I what am I like you
don't figure but you learn about
yourself when you help people and and
this is what we don't realize I can't
remember who said it recently it was
someone saying about Jeff Bezos but they
were saying that you know the scale at
which you succeed is the depth of the
problem you solve
and so even if you look at someone like
Jeff Bezos who's extremely successful
he's successful because he solved a
problem that many people have Bill Gates
is successful because he solved a
problem so even if you look at Monetary
success
even if you look at financial success it
comes from service any success comes
from service a musician is famous
because they're serving they're serving
You by understanding your feelings
making music you now feel comforted so
you follow them they have served you wow
so don't think of services just charity
and giving money which are beautiful
things which we all should do but don't
just limit your life to thinking I serve
on the weekends or I serve once a year
you can serve every month this podcast
is a certain no question right it's your
service because you're serving people by
giving them an alternative to just
watching some trash show but they're
actually here learning from you and
learning from the people that you bring
on the show venturing into the unknown
actually helps you know yourself better
according to researchers at the
University of Southern California
cross-cultural experiences where we
interact with people from different
backgrounds and walks of life our own
sense of self that comes longer travel
also shows us that no matter how
different we are we're also the same
Adam Gillings says when we engage with
other cultures we start to recognize
that most people treat us in similar
ways that produces an increase in trust
and that increased trust boosts our
overall faith in humanity our failure is
just great feedback in showing you how
much you care
if I failed at something and I really
cared about it I would keep going if I
failed at something and I didn't want to
get back up for it I probably don't care
that much and so failure is actually
showing you whether you care failure is
reminding you that you need to grow
somewhere and I think one of the things
that we forget is that you're failing at
something you're passionate about or
that you like but I always question
whether our expertise is right you
either feel boredom or frustration
so you feel boredom when your skills are
higher than your challenge
how many of you have ever experienced
that were your skills are really high
and then your challenge is really easy
and you're like I'm bored this is too
easy and he says you experience
frustration when your challenge is
greater than your skills
and so a lot of US settle that we
graduate from college maybe we go on a
few training days and then you never
learn anything new ever again
when actually our challenge is always
growing as our career grows and our
professional our personal life grows but
our expertise stays pretty much the same
and so that effort to go to the next
level failure is a reminder that you
want to invest in your expertise not
just your passion because you want it to
be a skill so I would say whenever you
feel frustrated by failure it's a good
sign that you can actually go deeper on
your expertise and level of work and
actually failure and reacting to failure
in that way is going to boost your
self-esteem and confidence more than
anything so actually sometimes failure
is just going to open doors that you
never imagined and I always say to
people you'll get to where you want in
life just not in the way you imagined it
we've been told for a long time that
you're the average of The Five People
You spend most time with we've had that
again and again and again and everyone's
always like get together with people you
want to be like and stuff and I've been
thinking about that a lot lately and I
was a lot of my friends were saying you
know Jay I'm always around people but I
still feel lonely yeah I don't know if
you've heard that like people like I'm
busy but I'm lonely I'm around people
especially here in LA and New York right
yeah and you feel that people feel
lonely and I said the challenge is we
need to stop getting together when you
start growing together and what I mean
by that is
schedule one experience once a week with
a friend where you're both growing
together choose an activity that neither
of you are a proa so don't go to yoga
class if one of you is a yoga Enthusiast
and the other isn't go somewhere where
there's a Level Playing Field why
because you now get a fresh experience
together it's so good because it boosts
your confidence it's curious if you're
bad totally and because you're going
together and you're both bad there's no
pressure and and my best memory of this
is once for training I was sent to
Chicago and it was 80 of us who'd never
worked together this was when I joined a
corporate company 80 of us were sent to
Chicago for training but we were told it
was Chicago actually we were two hours
outside of Chicago in the middle of
nowhere it would be at training 9 A.M to
6 p.m and then at 6 PM it was too late
to get into Chicago right so we'd have
to do something and the only thing we
could do is play sport because there
were all these Outdoor Sports places 10
of us every night would go out and we
played volleyball in the snow none of us
had ever played volleyball before I
could pick up the phone to any of these
people today because we all just had
this crazy unique experience together
and you're learning something and I
think we underestimate this learning
something every day is huge for your
self-care because you only feel good
about yourself when you feel you're
progressing we all have What's called
the monk mind and the monkey mind and as
monks we were trained to look at the
parts of our minds that we make mistakes
that fail that do things wrong is the
monkey mind if you can look at these
things as separate to who you are you
can now actually tackle them versus when
you think you are them it just needs to
guilt judgment self-criticism and
self-sabotage which I'm sure a lot of us
are privy to that we go through this
period where we like I can't believe I
did that I shouldn't have said that I
wish I just wish I didn't say that in
that moment and that doesn't change your
behavior it doesn't switch how you feel
it just creates more regret but when you
go wait a minute that's just the monkey
mind I've got that condition I've
associated with that type of environment
and energy let me approach it is
something that is separate of me
creating that distance and space from
our challenges lets us actually start
solving them there was this amazing
moment that I had one of the first days
I was at the monastery
and we were inside this room which was
almost like backstage like it wasn't
pretty it was like messy mixed up lots
of stuff everywhere which monasteries
are like these beautiful clean spaces
but there was this one room that was
almost like a dingy dirty basement
basically and so we're in this basement
I'm with one of my monk teachers and we
see this frame and he makes me look at
the frame and he says what do you see
and I was like well I see dust like
that's what I see it was just there was
all this dust over it and so he took his
robe and he wiped the dust and he wiped
it a few times because it was pretty
dusty a lot of the Dust came into my
face which I did not appreciate I was
coughing away and then finally when he
dust the mirror off I could see myself
it was a mirror it wasn't just a frame
it was actually a mirror and and he said
to me he said that your identity is like
this Dusty mirror he said when you first
try to understand who you are all you
see is dust and when you start cleaning
trying to figure out that self-awareness
the first experience you have is dust in
your face you cough you feel uneasy it's
not comfortable and then finally as you
keep dusting away on the mirror of your
identity you finally see who you truly
are he said most people never get there
because they're too interested in the
dust that everyone else throws at their
mirror and that's what we get lost in so
I've found that the best way of how as
you said Ashley how do you do that one
of my favorite ways to do something is
when I have a list of choices or
opportunities including this one I'll
write down the reason as to why I'm
saying yes to it so let's say I was
invited to five different Keynotes and I
write down each company that invited me
to it and on top of that company I'll
write down why would I say yes to it and
I'll be honest with myself and the
reason is either money the reason is ego
the reason is love the reason is Passion
the reason is
Envy jealousy right it could be any of
those and I'll honestly write down why I
would choose that or I would write it
down because I think my friend's gonna
think this because this is cool yeah
right I'm going to be able to message my
friends and say hey did you know what I
did and so I'll write down that and I'll
write the honest answer down and now
I'll go well now how do I upgrade this
to be turning up here for love how do I
upgrade this to be turning up here for
passion for purpose and so when you do
that activity you get to accept and be
honest with yourself for the emotion
that you're feeling but then you get an
opportunity to say how do I live an
upgraded life and how do I actually take
it a step up I like to set myself up by
saying what are the habits that I can
practice today that are going to make me
feel like my day is going in the right
direction and they are truly simple
thankfulness takes 30 seconds here's the
best way to practice it I don't
recommend a gratitude Journal I don't
recommend writing it down I recommend
expressing it making it specific and
personalizing it if you do that
gratitude actually has the ability to
boost your immune system it has the
ability to shift your perspective and
boost your mood but if you do it in a
way of I'm grateful for the air I'm
grateful for my kids I'm grateful for my
job that doesn't have that impact and
effect because it stays with you because
it stays within you and gratitude is
meant to be shared it's a gift that you
get to give someone else one of the
things I found was if you ask most
couples today
what is their most common activity to do
together
the majority of people I think the
studies show like
70 to 80 percent and I think it's
probably more if we really talk to
people
the number one thing they do with their
partner
is watch TV that is the most common
activity yes so now your two people are
watching TV and yeah we're not that
surprised by it two people are watching
TV and most likely you both have an iPad
or an iPhone in your hand too so now not
only are you in this world they're in
their world you're also supposedly
spending time together right in this
reality when the truth is you're
definitely not spending time together
but more importantly you're exchanging
Zero Energy yes so what are you
literally going to those devices and
that moment to turn off yeah to
de-stress correct but if that's the only
way that that's you're saying you're
turning off the relationship yeah you're
telling exactly and so do your sound
effect again
you're swiping yeah yeah yeah and and so
like you're doing all of that really
really fast I can't do the sound effect
but you're doing all of that really
really fast but this relationship is not
moving anywhere and so what I created in
the book and in my coaching practice is
four levels of intimacy and they're four
e's and that escalating levels of
intimacy so entertainment with your
partner is the lowest form of intimacy
and connection are you watching TV
watching a show that that is not even me
and you when if me and you ever watch
the TV show together ever never and we
would say that sure we may not know each
other deeply but we have deep
conversations that are intimate
vulnerable right open we've never
watched the TV show together right I've
never watched a TV show with Lewis Howes
yeah I've never even we hang out all the
time because we both live in LA I've
never watched a TV show with anyone in
that room yeah that I'm friends with I
don't think I have either yeah or a
movie for that matter we've never done
that every night we'd waste so much time
trying to figure out what to watch find
nothing to watch or find something that
really didn't work and then you're
dissatisfied with your relationship
because you go to sleep feeling so
unfulfilled so again I again I love
movies I I I even sometimes love video
games but the point is that can't be
your point of connecting with your
partner don't say that that is your
intimacy building that's great right the
next level of the the next state of uh
intimacy escalating One Step Above is
experiences and experiments and the way
I Define this experiences everyone knows
date nights restaurants trying to go out
together try and make an effort together
and I find even that can get really like
exhausting for people and boring and you
still end up on your phones that's why I
had the word experiments an experiment
is where both of you are a beginner
doing an activity together where both of
you are not Pros maybe you go Pottery
maybe you go kayaking maybe you go to a
paint class or try painting at home with
a YouTube channel maybe you're going to
try construct something you've never
done before yes take an activity with
neither of you are professionals or
experts so there's no ego and I promise
you you'll learn something new about
your partner
hidden skill they have a little Hidden
Gem in them so try and experiment A Step
Above from that you'll love this one is
education
take a course together read a book
together and even me and Riley struggle
with this read your own books and then
discuss about it that's what me and
Riley do so uh three nights a week Riley
will be reading a book she loves or
listen to podcasts she loves I'll be
reading a book I love and then we'll
gather together to excitedly share what
we learned because we don't like reading
the same stuff so you know and then the
highest level which really just
escalates so much intimacy and
vulnerability in a relationship is
engagement go and serve together help
out a soup kitchen a homeless shelter go
to the trenches go and serve together
because the connection you're going to
have when you've had a shared experience
of you've just given a bowl of soup to a
child in India together and you've
witnessed The Joy on their face and the
experience that they're having your the
intimacy you feel with your partner this
is nothing compares to it so I want
people to escalate up that journey and
realize there's more things we can do
than eat at restaurants and watch TV
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again it's expecting a
different result
right so if you find in your life when
you reflect about this question that
you're going through the same challenges
regularly actually remember a challenge
will never go away until you learn what
you're meant to learn from it so if
you're seeing the same challenge coming
up again and again in your personal
lives realize that it's trying to teach
you something as soon as you extrapolate
that lesson you'll get on to the next
challenge right they don't go away but
you go up a level you go up to the next
level so notice that as well remember
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over again expecting a different
result I write about things that I feel
I want to obsess about for years or
things that I've obsessed about for
years
and when it came to love I just saw in
my personal dealings my own experiences
when I sat down with couples that had
been together for 50 years in coaching
or couples that have been together for
five days I saw two things I saw people
who had discovered their passion they
were winning at their financial goals
but their home life was falling apart
their partner cheated on them their
partner was abusive towards the kids
maybe it wasn't that extreme maybe it
was just that they were just irritated
and angry all the time with their
partner and at home
their happiness was dictated by what was
happening at home yes and then I saw the
other side where I saw people who were
struggling at work maybe they had a boss
that talked down to them maybe they had
family that didn't believe in them
but their partnership was beautiful yeah
it was a source of strength and a source
of joy and so I looked at that I thought
you know what love is that Central
pillar in our life it's that lifelong
Pursuit
that we all know will give us the
greatest joy but it's something that was
never taught to us at school we were
just expected to know how to love yes
when we we work harder to get a degree
we work harder to get a driving license
than we do to get married which is
insane and settle down with someone and
so I wanted to dedicate the last few
years of my life to studying love to
researching love and coaching about love
and that's where the eight rules came
from we either put up a facade of
confidence or we hide our insecurities
or we try and find a way to disguise
the anxiety that we feel about ourselves
in order to cope with the world outside
of us and I think for me
I did that for many many years and
when I started to feel like I wanted to
walk this path
the fear and doubt that came in was fear
of failure there was a doubt around if I
had the skills or the ability
and just overall I think my vision had
shrunk and you're so right if someone
asked me in my teens
if this would have been possible I would
have said yes but if someone asked me my
twenties I would have said no and so
it's really interesting to see that
start comparison if if you ask me as a
15 year old if anything could be
possible I would I would have been much
more broad-minded and at 24 I'd become
much more small-minded because you start
thinking as to what's real
and what's possible and
you start also looking at the people
around you and going well where have
they got to and and then you start kind
of you know creating a little hierarchy
yeah what we say was the word the
comparison the comparison of where I am
actually learning can be something that
gives you a sense of achievement sense
of Drive sense of momentum and a feeling
like you're moving forward and towards
something when you dabble in articles
books podcasts you start to feel this
sense of being alive you have something
to share in every conversation you have
something to add you are more inclined
to listen to learn more and see how your
idea develops confidence comes from the
ability to engage in a conversation and
a feeling that you're moving forward the
feeling that you don't feel stuck or
trapped in a space learning and
consistently learning can truly
transform the way you feel about
yourself you start to trust yourself you
think to yourself wow I remember this
from what I read last week I was able to
apply that idea here at work today when
you start to connect the dots around
what you're learning and what you're
growing in that makes you feel a sense
of confidence I don't feel like we could
be stretching all the time agreed that
you could reach reach reach but you have
to recover with the replenish yeah you
have to be able to rest yeah also as
well yeah I'm trying to I'm trying to
add to that because I know we both like
alliteration but it's like stretch
stabilize and then forego like there's
also what's a sacrifice I guess like but
in a positive sense surrender surrender
yeah because I I found that I definitely
am shocked at my capacity
with the amount of things I do today
that I didn't know wherever possible so
if someone told me 10 years ago Jay one
day you're gonna do this this this this
this I would have said no way I can just
do one thing and we did exactly what you
said so every year I would stretch
myself every year and you're right you
can't just stretch straight stretch
stretch every month but every year I'd
add one thing so like first we started
creating videos and then after we
started creating videos we did the
podcast and then we did the podcast we
did our courses and programming and then
we did our then I wrote my book and then
after that you know so we stretched
ourselves a little and I stretched
myself a little every year but then we
stabilized but I've also found that I've
also had to let go of something
sacrifice some things that once upon a
time were really important to me but
today they're not as important and in
order to stretch and stabilize I had to
learn a sacrifice too and I think that's
something we struggle with like I think
one of our biggest limitations
is
wanting to hold on to stuff yeah right
like it's like there's no space to
shift away and hold on to something else
if we're holding on to this if I'm like
no no I want this to be there for the
rest of my life if you want a specific
New Life
or you have a path that seems
interesting to you you have to spend
more time on that path than around the
other people and so even though I didn't
spend a lot of time at the monks every
year that time was really deep in the
sense that I was fully immersed even if
I was there for a week or two weeks or a
month I was following the whole program
I was waking up at 4am I was having the
cold showers I was sleeping in the same
way I wasn't going there and treating it
like a vacation I was going there and
doing the work so in your case I'm
guessing that when you were writing a
Blog you were writing a Blog really well
you were trying to build a business
really well you were following your path
with a sense of intensity and even when
you're not getting the results or in my
case I couldn't just live as a monk for
the whole year
that intensity was so strong that I'd
come back really charged with all my
answers and all my voices in my head
saying no I know why I'm doing this and
so I was really certain because of my
immersiveness and I think a lot of us we
want to be certain but we're not
obsessed and it's hard to be certain
when you're not obsessed you can't be
half and half out in your practice of
something you want to be whether it's an
entrepreneur whether it's a Creator
whether it's a CEO or whether it's even
a parent like all of those roles are
really powerful but they're really hard
to do when you're kind of half in half
hour and so for me that was the first
thing I was fully immersed in who I
wanted to be what do you do in those
spiritual Retreats usually I like going
to the Eco Village in bulgar Vada and I
like just
switching off
I literally won't be on my phone I'll
completely unplug
and I like to just go back to living in
a meditative monk-like way in the way
that I used to
and to be able to just wake up at 4am
every day meditate again for many hours
reflect Journal introspect I find that
getting to do that for two to three
weeks a year is such a great reset I
find that naturally because of our
careers we're always on our phones and
we're always plugged in and that's great
and that's fantastic but I think once a
year it's so powerful to just completely
switch off so I won't reply to any
emails I won't check my text messages we
will have pre-prepared our content in
advance so that people are still served
and the community is taken care of but I
don't have to worry about any of that
what do you think is going to be the
lesson you're going to learn at the end
of this year if you could be in the
future what do you think your soul is
going to tell you that it's gonna be the
lesson and the thing for you to step
into or let go of into the next year
I think the lesson will be to and
everyone needs to do this and it comes
back to your point of season
is to live in the season that you have
reached and what I mean by that is that
there was a different energy that it
took to get here and it will be a
different energy to move forward and I
think it's really interesting because I
think we often stay in the same energy
State multiple years of our life because
we got used to it or we got familiar
with it and then years go by before you
realize you needed an energy shift and I
think when you see people who are
burnt out lost or confused or feel like
they wasted time it's because they never
realized that they stayed in the same
energy State uh that they were in when
they started and you have to accept that
time has changed and life has moved on
and you've learned new things and you've
gained new Clarity and so I think that
will be the lesson and letting go I
think will be I want to do I feel like
to get to this point I had to do a lot
of what
I didn't love and I think that that
should always get less and less and less
so I think a healthy life isn't one
where you only do what you love but it's
a life where you do less and less of
what you don't love and so I feel like
my life's always moving in that
direction and I think in a year from now
I have all the clarity and all the
opportunity
to start afresh as opposed to continuing
to just exist in the world of repeating
what's been done so this might be
unpopular opinion but I live by this and
it has truly been a game changer in my
world if it's not in the calendar it
won't get done it's not really a
priority right you have to make sure
that it's in your plan it's in your day
so I'm going to show you quickly what my
calendar and schedule look like that is
my life this month as you can see it's
color coded it's beautifully designed
and as I flick through this what you
realize is that every single day I have
everything from workout time to meal
times to scheduled off time all in my
calendar what this allows me to do is it
helps me prioritize both personal and
professional commitments and helps me
see both things in the same place if you
haven't put something in your calendar e
if it's something social I promise you
you'll either forget it or you won't
plan effectively around it when I know I
have a really big podcast or a really
big interview or if I know that I have a
big deadline on a day I don't then
surround that day with other difficult
and challenging tasks sometimes I'll
start my day with the most challenging
task of the day because I feel that I
need to start with a challenge and
sometimes I'll actually put it as the
last most challenging task of the day
because actually I want to build that
momentum when you have a schedule you
get context around how you feel that way
you manage your mental health and
well-being a million times better and
you do more with less time if there was
any way to sum up like what what did you
take from those three years like what
was it that kind of seeped into your
soul that that huge transformation that
you went through wherein you wanted to
live this different life completely what
what was it so I think there's a few
things
the first one and I'll share things that
I think people can relate to or are
digestible one of them was
adaptability
so you don't have a place you sleep you
sleep anywhere on the floor that's
available so you don't have a bedroom
you don't even have
a a section that's yours someone else
could sleep there tomorrow and you'd
have to sleep in their place there's no
space
um you know sometimes you get back and
there's no food left uh sometimes you're
out on the streets all day serving food
but you didn't get to eat
sometimes you've got a good night's
sleep sometimes you didn't like
there's just so much adaptability that
you learn sometimes you'd get somewhere
thinking you had a place to stay but
then you didn't like there was just so
much uncertainty in your day because you
don't get to pick what you eat there's
no menu there's no restaurant like it's
not like oh yeah I'll eat this today you
eat what you're given so you start
developing this
appetite for adaptability where whatever
happens you survive and you live and you
think oh wow like I can actually survive
either way and I think that that stays
with me today I mean we were just
talking about my team like I slept one
hour last night
um
but I've done that so many times and and
served all day that it it's just normal
it's it's it's part of the adaptability
training of you can just keep giving and
keep going
even without that now I wouldn't do that
every day that's only because I was on a
plane uh just to give that caveat I
don't recommend people burn themselves
out that's a very specific thing to this
this particular time that I'm in in this
next couple of weeks but the idea of
adaptability was huge would you want to
live as a monk again
yeah I mean I think I would want to uh I
think I would want to be wherever I can
best serve that's what I've realized
okay be where you can best serve because
there was a time in my life where being
a monk was the best way I could serve
but now if I was to go back there maybe
that wouldn't be service maybe that
would be selfishness because it would be
so personally motivated but actually
where I am right now is where I can
serve the most from it's almost like
saying you know every seed grows into a
tree but if the tree says I want to be a
seed again but the seed doesn't serve as
much as a tree does the tree gives
shelter it gives fruits it plants so
many new seeds and I think all of us
have to go through that journey of going
from seeds to trees I remember during
the pandemic it even after I was getting
calls from so many people that I work
with or so many people that my work is
involved in it could be companies it
could be people it could be individuals
and they were all just saying oh Jay
your work's so important now and I was
just like I've always believed mental
health is important I've always believed
that there is no quality of life without
good mental health and well-being and I
don't think that that's actually ever
changed or will ever change I think
that's a truth that will last the test
of time because as a human you get a
mind you get a body and you have to take
care of it and so I feel really happy
that people are coming to that
realization and reflecting I feel sad
that it's coming because of pain and
suffering and I feel
you know it it saddens me that we have
to go through so much tragedy and pain
to come to a point of realizing actually
I have to take care of this but I know
even in my own life that's what I had to
do like the only time I took my body
seriously was when my body gave up on me
and the only reason why I worked really
hard on my mind at times was because it
was challenging and so I think we do
find self-care in times of discomfort we
have a lot of fun together we've had a
lot of fun over the last 10 years for
sure without a doubt like whether it was
when we've traveled together when we've
started
joyo together when we've uh moved
whether we you know we're in this tiny
shoebox apartment or whatever it was
we've had a great time but the greatest
great time is when you're learning and
growing together because you actually
learn how to improve your relationship
and that's what makes your relationship
better yeah so when I talk about your
partner as your Guru what I love is that
if you look at Eastern Traditions gurus
are not the people who tell you what to
do or preach to you or act smarter than
you the guru like the monk gurus they
would come and sit at the back of the
class and listen to a young Monk and
give a talk like that's what gurus did
or when you bow down to an elder Guru
the guru would bow down to you on the
floor even if they were twice your age
like the guru was not a figure that made
you feel inferior it's not authoritative
yeah but the guru was a figure that
constantly made you feel like they
believed in you and that you had
potential and that you had value to
offer and so when I wrote this chapter
called your partner is your Guru I break
down the qualities of a student and I
break down the qualities of a guru and
all of the qualities our Guru is
generally your partner who believes in
you and I found what I found in
relationships is that it's so easy for
you to be the most critical person of
your partner yeah it's so easy for you
to say that oh yeah you're just the
worst and you're so like lazy and you're
just like you know ambitious enough and
you know organized they're not like it's
so easy and I found so many couples were
in that space even if you don't say it
we feel that about our partners because
people say it to other people the amount
of people that come to me and say my
partner's ambitious enough he doesn't
work hard enough like oh she doesn't
understand enough she's too clingy like
we have these negative views and
actually we should be the ones who see
the potential in our partner of course
Beyond any and I make this very clear in
the book beyond any abusive or toxic
relationships we should look at the
potential in our partner we should be
the ones who are like making them feel
like they can grow and become something
of course not ridiculous in stupid ways
but in a healthy way how does your
morning routine which I think we spoke
about the first time you came on my show
how does that help you
tap into your purpose or I guess
continually refine your purpose because
I think there's something really
powerful in what you do each morning
that many of us can learn from
so my morning routine is made up of
four key habits and these four habits I
have in the form of an acronym called
time t-i-m-e and so t-i-m-e the T stands
for thankfulness I start my day with
thankfulness and gratitude and the way I
do that rangan is I have a little
Post-It note next to my bed that says
what are you grateful for and so the
first thing I see in the morning is this
Post-It note that says what are you
grateful for it's a question back at me
I remember when I used to have uh not a
bedside table I'd have it on my ceiling
I'd have it on my bedside wall and what
I love about that is you can write down
any question you want this comes from
the idea that we have 60 to 80 000
thoughts per day and studies show that
80 percent of them are negative and
repetitive
now that's quite scary to look at and
the truth is you can't control Sig sixty
to eighty thousand thoughts per day but
you can control the first thought of the
day and the last thought of the day and
so for me when I wake up to that Post-It
note I am training myself to make the
first thought of the day A Grateful one
a thankful one the i in my acronym
stands for intention or insight and I
try and set my intention for the day uh
usually my intention is I want to be of
service I want to be able to give love I
want to express love I want to be an
ambassador of
purpose and compassion in my life in my
day and then there could be a more
specific intention like today it's like
well I hope I get to share energy with
wrong good I know wrong's been going
through a lot of personal things today I
hope that my energy he's choosing to
spend time with me I hope that that can
serve him serve his community and so I'm
setting a really powerful intention uh
the m t i m m is for meditation I
meditate every morning I do three types
of meditation which is what I was
trained in as a monk it's meditations I
teach it's breath work for the body
visualization for the mind and mantra
for the heart or soul and so I do my
three techniques what I find is really
what I'm trying to do is in the morning
is align my body and mind because what I
find is wrong and we usually wake up in
the morning and our body is ahead of our
mind how many times anyone is listening
or watching have you ever felt well your
body's running around but your mind is
just still in bed or you experience the
opposite you wake up and your mind is
racing trying to do everything but your
body is feeling exhausted and so for me
breath work brings my body and mind
together visualization allows me to
visualize the day what am I going to do
how am I going to show up who are the
people that I'm going to meet what kind
of energy are we going to exchange and
then the Mantra or sound meditation is
the repetition of sacred sounds
affirmations that again become my
internal dialogue and then ears exercise
movement at the moment I've been hiking
I've been doing a 45 minute to an hour
hike every day to get some really good
cardio in
to get my heart rate uh moving and so
that's my morning routine pretty much
five days a week it's probably a couple
of days a week that I'm a bit more
flexible I think it's pretty important
for people to be able to be alone before
they try to get into a relationship yeah
I think
we've created this feeling in society
where loneliness
is the enemy like being alone is seen as
a weakness
so when someone goes to school and
throws a birthday party and not many
people show up you're unpopular whereas
if lots of people showed up you were
really important you were significantly
brutal I can think of few things that
would be more devastating to a kid than
no one showing up to your birthday
exactly and that's how it's framed
that's how it's talked about and then
the next thing is like would you tell
your kids if they if they went to have a
birthday party and nobody shut up Jay
would you really be like hey Solitude is
a good thing like how would you well I'm
not dad so I I can't say but but what I
would say is that I would change it in
the invite process
so I would ask them to only invite
people that they felt really connected
to or they felt they really vibed with
them wanted to celebrate their birthday
with so I think the challenge is when
you're a kid you also hand out way too
many invites so I think that's what ends
up happening is that you think a good
birthday party is a packed room and even
I mean people still feel that till
they're 50 60 70 like that is until
they're dead until they're dead right
like you feel a good birthday party or a
good event even when people say like
when I die like if there's loads of
people there that will be a thing I
think we've just programmed ourselves to
believe that if we're not surrounded by
people we can't celebrate and we can't
be celebrated it has to be about scale
of how many people are there and I would
say that's one measurement but the other
measurement is the depth of how well
they know you I know tons of people who
threw a great birthday party at 50 500
people showed up and they felt actually
I went I actually I went to a birthday
party this year it was a big birthday
party
and I was speaking to the person whose
party it was and they were like so many
people invited people I didn't know to
my birthday party and they felt lonely
at their own birthday party
I don't want if I have had kids I
wouldn't want them to feel that and even
for myself I don't want to be in that
position I'd rather have
I saw this thing on um Instagram and it
was someone who posted like it was like
a 10 this is in um British currency it
was like 10 pence and then one pound and
so 10 pence is larger circumference than
the pound but the pound is greater in
value and so the the caption on
Instagram said that my circle has shrunk
in size but has increased in value and I
was thinking that that to me resembles
the kind of life I would want for myself
and for my children if I had them but if
I could have both that would be amazing
obviously but I don't know how real it
is to be able to say we can have both so
I think what I'm trying to say with
Solitude is that
if there isn't a sense that I am happy
with myself with my own company with the
thoughts that circle around in my mind
imagine how complex that is when you add
another confused individual who's not
happy with their thoughts not happy with
who they are not happy with their mind
and now in a relationship you're putting
two confused people together why is
there pain why is their Fallout why is
there so much disappointment in a
relationship in my opinion and from the
perspective of the Eastern studies is
that because there's an internal
dissatisfaction in both people that
they're now bringing to each other
and so the strength of solitude is using
that time
I've still not found a better solution
for self-awareness than Solitude
because in solitude it's the only place
you get to hear your own voice
and make sense of other people's
opinions if I'm standing in the middle
of a group of 100 people and they're all
yelling their opinions at me chances are
some of them are going to rub off some
of them are contagious some of them I'm
gonna reject and I don't get the space
and time to make sense of what's my
voice and what's noise whereas when I
get time
to myself
I get the opportunity to reflect on and
introspect and go do I want that thought
to be mine
how does that fit into my life how do I
feel about this right you get to have
that dialogue with yourself and I feel
we've lost the art of self-tile
self-talk and self-dialup you're the
bottom of the pile you put everybody
else ahead of your own needs and like
you say you crash and burn and then you
go oh right how am I gonna help myself
here it's a real cultural shift that we
need to make to actually be kinder to
ourselves it's quite simple but I'm
saying it from the point of view that I
have not nailed this one at all yeah
same same and I always say to people and
I'm saying this to myself now as I'm
saying it out loud which is uh when
things are bad work hard and when things
are good work harder and no one wants to
hear that because when things are good
we just want to enjoy it we just want to
live it we just want to appreciate it
but we don't realize that when things
are tough that's when you put in the
extra hours but when things are really
good A little bit of extra refinement
and fine-tuning means you can stay there
it means you can keep thriving and keep
growing otherwise is that complacency is
what leads to that crash and so if times
are good for you right now I really hope
you'll invest a bit more in yourself if
times are tough for you right now then
naturally you'll be investing in
yourself uh but yeah just don't I I've
seen that in my own life like whenever
things are good I'm always trying to
plant the seeds for the future we've all
been programmed to say oh your strengths
are they're fine they're good the way
they are but why are you not performing
at this
and so the one way to know your
strengths
is to ask yourself what do you do that
you feel the most confidence doing and
it could be something as simple as I'm
great at organizing birthday parties it
could be like that may be your skill
right that may be your strength or it
may be something like I'm really good at
putting on makeup or it could be that I
have a great sense of fashion it could
be any of those things and if you don't
know it yet you can also do an exercise
where you sit down with a colleague a
family member and a friend because you
need people from all areas of your life
and you ask them what do you think I do
that I excel in that I stand out in or
if you could trust me to do one thing in
your life for you what would that one
thing be
and when you ask that to people in a
reflective way really asking for that
presence you might be surprised by what
they say
and that's such a powerful question to
ask because someone may actually say
something like to you like Jay I think
your greatest strength is just knowing
what to say to me when I most need it
and you may think well that's not a
strength you can do anything with but it
is it is a strength that you can do a
lot with if you are okay with accepting
that of course I want someone to say to
me oh Jay you're you're an athlete like
Cristiano Ronaldo and you could play
football and get the Ballon d'Or and win
all these trucks but that's not my
reality
and so I feel that that's the place that
I would start with strengths
and there was a great study done on the
healthy wealthy and wisest people in the
world and they were asked if you could
invest in what you're good at
your average at or what you're bad at
where would you put your money and so if
you take a hundred percent how would you
divide that as a ratio
and if you ask this I want everyone
who's listening and watching at home
right now to do this exercise and you
may write down 33 33 33 you may write
down 40 40 20 you may write down 10 10
80 whatever you write down
the most healthy wealthy wisest
successful people on the planet will say
theirs is a hundred zero zero or 80 10
10 they go all in on their strengths
because they know that if they go all in
on their strengths they can become
exceptional at it
now here's the caveat
when it comes to your hard skills focus
on your strengths but when it comes to
your soft skills focus on your
weaknesses now you got to tell me which
is which yeah so hard skills are things
like excel math uh product design using
a video camera uh script writing
speaking these are all hard skills in
the sense that they're very clearly
defined very tangible uh you can really
measure them it's almost like a skill
that's measurable your soft skills are
like emotional intelligence listening
compassion empathy these are all soft
skills or considered soft skills and
those are where you focus on your
weaknesses because they can actually end
up tripping you up while you're trying
to become the best at doing the hard
skill so you may be the best
videographer in the world but if you
don't know how to listen to your
community and your team then no one's
going to want to work with you and so to
me that's the missing link that we're
we're actually the other way around we
put all our emphasis on getting better
at our weaknesses and our hard skills
and we think that because we're
empathetic and good people that that
will be enough and it doesn't work that
way I remember a piece of advice from
Richard Branson now he didn't give it to
me personally even though I like to
think that he did I may hear his voice
in my head when I think it through but
he said This brilliant statement he said
that when you get an opportunity you
think you're not ready for say yes and
then figure out how to do it and I
remember reading that when I was 18
years old and I thought wow that's
genius I'm going to try that out I'm
going to experiment with that statement
now that a statement's got me into a lot
of trouble sometimes but most of the
time it's worked why because when I said
yes to an opportunity I didn't feel I
was ready for I then had the incentive
and the Catalyst to go out there and
study learn build grow whereas when I
waited to be ready for an opportunity I
never had the push to grow hence going
back to that place we sometimes need to
go back to feeling like we have nothing
to then feel like we have an energy to
go out and Achieve something again
you've got to put yourself in that
mindset so actually what I'd say to that
is don't ever feel that you're not ready
even if you are say you are and then go
and learn how to do it don't let the
opportunity pass now in the case that
you've already let it pass don't worry
just change your attack next time that's
it's as simple as that what would you
say to somebody though who is in a
relationship just tough question start
out early yeah go but I'm in a
relationship I just heard you say that
and I go not only is that not our
pattern because sometimes relationships
take patterns yeah not only is that not
the pattern but I feel like this
person's almost competing against me and
sometimes even even though I feel like
there's some sort of Love there they
really aren't supporting yeah helping
not only they're helping my goals
they're not supporting the goals that I
have does that mean you're not in a
loving relationship or are there some
strategies you can have to better
connect where we get on the same page on
that I think thing first place I started
is that there uh when I was a monk I
learned about these what the monks
called the three cancers of the mind and
they are comparing complaining and
criticizing and what I find in
relationships is that we're constantly
operating in one of these Dynamics
you're either complaining about your
partner you're comparing your partner to
other people or you're criticizing your
partner and when you're living in these
three ways there's no room for growth
and the problem is your partner can't be
doing anything that I talk about in this
book because they never went to that
class they never got to go to that
school and neither did you so what you
just said so beautifully we just assume
people know how to love let me just take
that idea do you just assume someone
knows how to drive a car right do you
just assume someone knows how to be a
doctor do you just
that someone knows how to fly a plane
like you would never assume that but we
assume that love must ah Love's easy
right Love's easier than driving a car
and Love's easier than flying a plane no
it isn't it's hot it's so much harder
there's a thought I've been having
recently and it's that
Comfort creates self-care
but discomfort creates self-respect
right like it's what you're saying that
the one more discomfort every day that's
where self-respect comes from yes you
don't great term yeah you don't you
don't start to trust yourself or build
self-esteem or believe in yourself
because you just say it to yourself it's
coming what you just said you gotta then
take one more meeting and see what you
learn you go out there and take one more
risk one more discomfort the people that
I know that are the most successful and
happy have more uncomfortable
conversations agreed they have more
uncomfortable days they're more
discomfort in their lives yes but
selected discomfort but one of the other
things that I'm asking from now I'm like
going into like the people that I know
that that I'm thinking about and could
see their faces and and I want them to
know that I'm asking for them a lot of
the time one more in the wrong direction
that's right can also be
really misguiding
sometimes uh people and I know you're a
person of Faith too and so so we can
touch on this sometimes we're climbing
the mountain and we keep doing one more
but we're actually going further away
from who we are who we want to be our
faith our partners right we've we know
people who've built
multi-billion dollar companies but lost
their kids that's right or they've
become famous and Rich but they've uh
their partner cheated on them you know
like we know a lot of those stuff and
you know people who didn't do all of
that that's happened too it's both ways
how does one use one more and make sure
it's in the right direction we've all
heard the quote good things come to
those who wait maybe your father said it
to you maybe your mother said it to you
maybe your uncle or Auntie or your
friend or maybe your teacher said it to
you right good things come to those who
wait I want you to tell me what you
think of that quote has that principle
worked for you has that in life made any
difference right I want to hear your
view so in the comment section just type
away let me know what you're thinking
let me know what you think of that
advice that piece of advice that good
things come to those who wait because
today we're talking about creating
opportunities so actually I want to
change that my opinion on that quote is
that we need to change that from good
things come to those who wait right to
good things come to those who create the
people that actually create their own
opportunities the people that take
responsibility and ownership to make a
difference in their life and the lives
of other people and as we've been
building This Global conscious Community
I know so many of you have stimulating
ideas about how you're going to bring
about change we often think that
creative opportunity means it has to be
rushed or hurried or it means you have
to have lots of stuff going on and
sometimes that can get quite draining it
can get quite overwhelming it can start
to feel as if we don't know how we're
going to move forward but what I notice
now is that we need to balance that
theory with the value of creating
opportunities there's a great
quote by a Roman philosopher named
Seneca where he said that luck is what
happens when preparation meets
opportunity right that's what happens
when preparation meets opportunity
something that we don't really have a
lot of talked about today and I was
thinking about I used to have an
economics teacher and this economics
teacher I remember the first day he
walked into school
he walked into school I still I believe
we had white boards by that time I'm not
that old he had whiteboard and on the
Whiteboard he wrote down
he goes failing to prepare is preparing
to fail and I remember all of us is
bursting out laughing and we just
thought oh my God is is he a philosopher
or an economics teacher right he wrote
uh failing to prepare is preparing to
fail he wrote that down on the board and
I'm gonna get to myself I'm going oh my
God another one of these philosophers
because I wasn't even into philosophy
myself and when he wrote that down now
when I look back and I think wow that
was such a powerful statement that was
so true so Seneca Roman philosopher says
the same thing he says luck is what
happens when preparation meets
opportunity so one of the things I
wanted to talk about how do we create
opportunity in our life when we're
trying to develop patients within
ourselves you'll find that when you're
working to your purpose when you're
working in a connected way when you're
working in the direction where you feel
focused you naturally develop patience
we often feel we don't have patience
when things aren't working out and
things usually don't work out when we're
not working in a way that works for us
one of the things that I wanted to speak
to you about talking about that is the
ability to really understand times at
which when we need to make things almost
difficult again now I don't want you to
invite difficulties into your life
that's not what I'm recommending but
hear me out for a second what I'm trying
say is that often you have to go back to
feeling feeling like you have nothing so
that you can create something again a
great example of this was actually Elon
Musk and I don't know how many of you
have read his autobiography it's
absolutely phenomenal sorry biography
and he talked about that when he sold
PayPal his earnings were 180 million now
he split that straight away I think in a
matter of about three months he put 100
million into SpaceX he put 70 million
into a Tesla and he put 10 million into
Solar City if you add that all up if
you're quick at Madison you've probably
done it already that's 180 million
already gone right he said that he was
struggling to pay rent right he had to
borrow money to pay rent the guy's a
millionaire why did he do that he says
that he had to feel that desperation
again that ability to want to make a
change he had to re-live that you can
create opportunity in your life if
you're someone who thinks maybe it's
your business maybe it's in your
relationships maybe it's at work
wherever it is whether you're an
entrepreneur you're trying to grow your
career Wherever You Are are we all need
to create opportunities how can we do
that how do we all take that leap of fit
so you're somewhere you're okay with
where you're at you're probably
saying okay you're with where you're at
you're comfortable with it but you know
that there's more out there for you how
do you take that leap of faith one of
the ways that I believe we take that
leap of faith is actually launch
something new then talk about it rather
than the other way around often what we
do is we spend a lot of our time talking
about doing something and we never get
around to actually making it happen but
actually what I recommend is just start
doing something small I love talking
about Facebook when Facebook first
launched it was only meant to be for
Harvard right my exactly where you made
it it works for Harvard it then branched
out to the ivy league universities in
the states in Denver and start over to
Cambridge and Oxford and the top
universities and institutions in England
and then I believe across the world but
notice that it's a testing period and
you see loads of tech firms do this
brilliantly today they're experts at
starting small and scaling up so my main
recommendation is start small do not try
and start big and really think about how
you can launch something and then talk
about it don't start talking about
something first usually when you throw
out an idea if you get criticism for it
straight away you're less likely to see
it through I think one of my first
things in failure
is don't take it more personally than it
actually is and I'll give an example of
that when I was applying to 40 companies
that all rejected me before an interview
yeah all I was getting was an automated
response saying your application will
not go any further
I can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a interaction with me they
just saw my name they saw I'd been a
monk for three years that resume is
useless I mean what's your transferable
skills like sitting in silence surprise
surprise no one wants to hire a monk and
so they rejected you but that's not
personal because they didn't meet me in
person but what if they had me right so
that's the first thing the first step is
don't take all fear failure I'll give an
example me and you we reach out to
countless guests to be on our podcast we
say no all the time we're saying all the
time but if I don't hear a no from the
guest directly that's not a no like
someone's team can say no someone's
assistant can say no someone's PR team
can say no but until they say no
personally it's not a no okay but when
they do say no then that's enough yeah
so then let's move how do you deal with
that type of failure yes so if I deal
with a failure where someone meets me in
person and gets to know Jay you're
horrible you suck like I don't want to
deal with a monk ever in my life yeah I
would never go on your show I'm never
listening to you never yeah how do you
deal with that type of so I've had you
say this I've said a couple of times and
I'm sure it's been repeated a bunch of
times around how I genuinely believe
failure has feedback feedback and and so
for me it's like failure has the ability
to actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong I've been there many
times and then you're like I felt good
for a moment yeah and then I feel empty
again totally and and so that's the
thing about failure in the second half
is you have to see failure as an
improvement if if I'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has made me more hungry taught me so
much more about myself and made me up my
game we don't ask people in our life
interesting questions and therefore we
don't get interesting answers if you ask
the same boring everyday questions to
everyone in your life you're simply
going to receive the same answers as you
did yesterday last week and even last
year this is something I learned on my
podcast on purpose I get to sit down
with some of the most fascinating Minds
in the world but I've learned that I
have to ask the right question in order
to receive an answer that's going to
help all of you that are listening at
the end of my podcast I have this final
five round where they have to answer the
questions in either one word to one
sentence and almost every time I'll say
okay ignore my rule tell me how you
really feel because the answer is so
fascinating now I want to share with you
some of the questions that I asked
during that time that I think will
benefit you when you're really getting
into a conversation as well if you met
your younger self today what would make
them happy and what would make them sad
what situations make you feel awkward
and why this one's actually a great
Icebreaker because they might say this
very moment with some curiosity and
humor what did you recently buy that you
now regret I love that one some of my
favorite ones that I ask on my podcast
uh what's the best advice you've ever
received and what's the worst advice
you've ever received you'll be shocked
by some of the answers that people share
and my ultimate favorite if you could
create one law that everyone in the
world had to follow what would it be
this is a question that has been shared
for thousands and thousands of years but
it truly helps you understand someone's
values and one of the biggest mistakes
we make in our communication with our
teams and groups of people around us is
that we assume we already know
or we come up with a situation in the
workplace which we've heard of before
and we assume it's exactly the same as
before when the truth is Human
Experience may be similar but it's never
the same for the person going through it
and so when we start thinking like
children when we look at things through
fresh eyes when we hear the same problem
time and time and time again but we're
able to approach it and say no I'm going
to be more present I'm going to be more
conscious I'm going to be more
empathetic and I'm really going to
listen into what this truly is
what the challenge truly is that's when
we accept childlike thinking not
childish childlike and when you listen
to people around you how can you bring
that same perception and say I know I
feel like I've heard this before I know
I think I know the answer already but
I'm still going to listen because there
still may be something more for me to
understand what status quo can you
challenge that will make you better more
effective more productive and creative
how many times do we say that to
ourselves this is just the way it is we
just accept it the way we're
communicating the way we're communicated
to the way we're thinking the way people
are thinking about us where can we start
again as a team as a community
applying that same mindset to shifting
things we will never be able to solve
the toughest problems inside
organizations inside our teams when we
don't adopt Community thinking when we
don't realize that someone from another
industry from another area from another
space could Inspire us when we don't
realize that if we're not working
together or if we're not thinking
win-win
it's really hard to shift things is that
really the best way we can do it are we
really going to accept the status quo
are we really going to say we need that
critical thinking but we need to do it
together not to each other
but together often critical thinking
happens to each other that person's not
getting it right how can we all
critically think together as a community
I would encourage all of you to think
about what you do on a daily basis
and redefine it redescribe it come up
with your own vocabulary to talk about
the incredible work you do
because the more meaningful you think it
is the more meaningful your team will
think it is
and the better your well-being the
better your mental health the better
your own communication the better your
ability to deal with stress and pain and
so when we can explain what we do
meaningfully when we can give it that
vocabulary when we can have the
community mindset for the people we work
with and the people who work with us
we can truly adopt what it means to be a
connected thinker Norman Cousins once
said the tragedy of life is not death
but what we Let Die inside of us while
we're still alive
the hardest thing to realize is the
number one reason our dreams don't come
true is because we don't come through
ourselves
pretend they don't
it makes no sense it's been locked for
so long we've even forgotten its name
everything we do today feels like it's
all the same our dream is like a
prisoner trapped within us a vacant
listener lacking more Vision until
someone comes and says
you don't see your own potential
sometimes we need an internal
intervention but when we can't have that
a guide or a mentor or a coach can
provide the trigger and Catalyst for
deeper understanding and when they ask
us
it's your passion we shrug it off and
say that stuff doesn't happen and then
they push us a little further trobus to
think deeper they're always focused on
helping us find a hope inside of
ourselves
let me ask you would you let someone who
had incredible potential die right next
to you you would never do that so why do
we let them die right inside of us
that's why the missing link is a coach
a coach reminds you of your potential
and sees what you don't see some of us
get given people some of us get given
lessons but all of us get given moments
to change the trajectory of Our Lives we
can't imagine Kobe Bryant without Phil
Jackson we can't imagine Serena Williams
without Patrick moratoglu we can't
imagine Tom Brady without Alex Guerrero
Maya Angelou said people will forget
what you said they'll forget what you
did but they'll never forget how you
made them feel Picasso said that the
meaning of life is to find your gift and
the purpose of life is to give it away
coaches can be found in books mentors
can be found in schools
guides will be found throughout life
we don't have to be in the same room to
understand their point of view
we don't have to know them for them to
show you the way we just have to have
the burning desire to learn
everyone we admire has been coached
directly or indirectly we're coached by
our exes unconsciously we're coached by
Nature indirectly we're coached by
coaches intentionally
everyone you admire has someone behind
them someone you've probably never heard
of someone you might not have seen
Zig Ziggler said a lot of people have
gone further than they thought
because someone else thought they could
you have to know whether you're someone
who likes to be thrown in the deep end
or whether you're someone who likes to
build up incrementally I'm generally
someone who jumps into the deep end so I
was pushed in for five minutes and that
works for me because for me I'm the kind
of person who needs to be pushed off to
break the mental barrier to then go back
and build a habit that's my
self-awareness I became a monk in order
to learn these things I'm an extreme
person that's how I learn and build
habits but someone else goes to me
actually Jay I like meditating for five
minutes a day and it works for me and
now I have confidence I can do 10
minutes a day I can do 15 and I love
that so I don't think it's an either or
I genuinely don't that's not a cop out I
think you have to know who you are and
so if I want to learn something I'll
schedule the whole weekend if I wanted
to learn archery I would set up archery
classes for eight hours a day all
weekend I wouldn't learn it by doing
archery once a week because I want to
figure out whether I'm deeply interested
and care about this enough to act really
commit to it weekly but that's my
mindset that's who I am so I think the
first thing I say is 10 minutes alone
every week where you sit and you just
observe your thoughts and write down
every thought that comes up this is
weird
I hate this it's boring
oh I can't believe Jay and Tom told me
to do this right like whatever else is
coming up and write it down and just
become comfortable becoming aware of
your thoughts and what you find is that
the first time you do this it is just
going to be random noise like that what
shall I eat tonight what's going on it's
just going to be that stuff it might be
I hate this I'm uncomfortable this is
not fun I'm bored like it will just be
natural dialogue like that what you'll
find is the next time you do it or the
next after a couple of times that you do
it you now might start asking
interesting questions you might now
start noticing a pattern of thoughts
that repeats itself like I've just been
thinking for a week about what that
person said to me about how I look or
I've been thinking about what that
person said to me about
something I did online like and it's
just been in my mind and it keeps
repeating itself now you're going to
start to find what you spend most your
time on so studies show we have 60 to 80
000 thoughts per day and eighty percent
of them are negative and eighty percent
of them are repetitive so if our life is
not transforming our thoughts now if I
ask you what are you thinking about
you're a self-aware person I'm pretty
sure you could tell me on any given
moment what you're thinking about you
ask most people what they're thinking
about
the reaction will be an emotion like I'm
just stressed I've got too much on at
the moment but we can't be really clear
so what this is giving you is a Clarity
of what are those repeating negative
thoughts and how do we want to change
them so that's Step One is a even
becoming aware of the thoughts so if I
ask an average person when you wake up
in the morning what's the first thought
you have oh I'm tired that's the first
thought for most people you finally made
it to Coffee you add your morning coffee
and you're thinking God I hope this
coffee gets through me through the day
because I'm so tired second time you've
had the door you get to lunch time
you're like God is it only lunch time
like and I can't even eat lunch because
I'm busy working God I'm so tired you
get the 6 p.m maybe you've got to work
an extra hour because no one finishes
work at six anymore seven PM you finish
you're good I'm exhausted I can't wait
to get home you get home and somehow at
11 37 PM you get the courage to watch
another episode and you repeat the cycle
right that's a six thoughts in the same
day I think kindness spreads faster and
kindness is easy to experience and it
actually effect on how you feel so one
of the things I've seen which is so
beautiful is that when people are
sharing my videos on Facebook it's like
they feel that they're getting to spread
kindness they're not spreading it
because it's smart they're not spreading
it because it's provocative they're
spreading it because they feel that if
they spread it with their Community
they're also part of spreading kindness
and I think that's what I love about it
that kindness doesn't have any languages
it doesn't have any barriers like it's
beyond all of that kindness is a
language we can all speak so this is a
quote from Nelson Mandela where he said
no one is born hating another person
and if they can learn to hate they can
be taught to love when we're children we
naturally are caring compassionate and
kind I actually saw this really good
video on social media of uh child
watching cartoon and the cartoon
character started to cry and so the
little girl she crawled up to the screen
and she took a napkin and she started to
wipe the tear and like that's how we are
as children and then we we're almost
we're wired for generosity but then
we're educated for greed so our life
becomes around getting and success and
achievement and like getting it doing
whatever it takes and that's what
kindness gets removed so the only way to
bring that kindness into children's
lives is through encouraging things like
sharing and collaboration you know
encouraging things like not ownership of
a toy or an aspect but recognizing that
things are connected what's next in
terms of actualization and ultimate
thank you for asking that question so
first of all I I don't think any social
media can give us self-actualization I
wish it could that'd be so cool if you
could take a pill or watch a video or
whatever it may be and that it just gave
you that moment it would be amazing but
I think what's next is we have come to a
place where I think people are looking
for Alternatives that people have become
dissatisfied with the norm it's why
social media videos around the positive
elements are growing because all of us
are seeking and I think that's awesome
and I think the biggest thing we have to
do is I think everyone has to sit down
and just seek a step further and just go
okay I found this piece of content
online that inspired me that moved me
what do I do now about it in my real
life those are a three C's of growth
right you need a coach if you want to
get good at everything you have to have
a coach there is no one who's got good
at anything without having a coach
whether it was conscious or subconscious
right whether you knew it or you didn't
know it the second thing is it needs to
be consistent it's not good enough to
hear someone once at a conference it's
not good enough to meet someone once a
month you need that consistency we
shower every day we eat every day right
you have to do both to stay alive so you
need to refuel and renew your mind every
single day it needs to be consistent and
the third thing is it needs Community
where if you're growing without
community
it's not sustainable all of us need
friends that want the same thing all of
us need friends to discuss things with
to grow with to hear the same ideas back
to reflect with there's two types of
content creators one is the sellout and
one is the selfish so a selfish Creator
only creates videos for themselves you
know when you make a video I'm like I
would so watch this right and it's like
yes you're the only person that would so
watch that and I've made some of those
videos too where you just think you're
so smart and you look so cool but that's
selfish Creator you make stuff that only
you understand right no one else would
get it a lot of phds or scientists end
up making this mistake where they talk
on a plane where most of us have no idea
what they're talking about and then you
have the the sellout content creator the
sellout only makes for the audience the
seller goes oh what's trending this week
let me make a video about this oh oh
that buzzword or I'm gonna Chuck it in
there and that doesn't work either
because that hard to refuel it's hard to
feel meaningful so the truth is the
marriage between the two you want to
listen to people to find out what their
challenges are but you want to draw from
whatever you're learning to serve that
challenge as a monk in the three years
you were a monk and many people stay
monks until they leave this earth right
and and I'm understanding that you're
saying monks don't date monks are
celibate so can you refresh my memory
why that is and it's not just in one
kind of Monk right you see this across
cultural different
so why is that can you remind me I mean
there's many different reasons
and I can't speak from anyone I'm beyond
my tradition obviously uh but
I would say that the number one reason
is to create a sense of focus
and
Aligned Energy so if we all believe that
we have
a certain amount of energy and the more
things we add to that the more it takes
away our energy in different directions
now being sellable or getting into a
relationship is one of those but it's
the same as having a career as a monk
you don't have a job right and so it's
the same reasoning where it's like well
what if all of your energy was placed in
self-mastery and self-realization and
you didn't use your energy for anything
else or anyone else or anyone else would
you not have the opportunity to go deep
into the self
and so it's not about women or celibacy
or like it's not about the external idea
of like some people like oh well money's
bad and women are bad and that's where
you stay and it's like well no it's got
nothing to do with that it's not like
you don't have a job because money is
better you don't have a partner because
you know a certain gender is bad it's
it's the idea that how could you limit
all your distractions or how could you
limit all your focuses and energy to the
pursuit of self-realization and anything
above the pursuit of self-realization is
seen as unimportant at that stage of
life
and I think there's Beauty in that I
think when you when I think about
getting three years of my life to have
an exclusive focus on self-realization I
would say it works it's fascinating how
everything is just a thought I was
talking to
a couple of friends a couple of nights
ago and I was talking to him about the
the hernia surgery that I just went
through
and he was saying to me like how tough
was it and I had a tough version of it
we were just talking about it some
people wake up and in the next 24 hours
they're fine it's taken me four weeks to
feel 50 again right like that that's how
I feel maybe 50 60 again I know people
have gone through for 12 months right
they're still here yeah people are still
going through it and so he said to me he
was just like do you like how did you
not let yourself get depressed because
like the first week I couldn't walk
uh and I had something called
atelectasis which is like a partial
collapse of the lungs so I couldn't
breathe every three breaths almost and
then my wife rushed me to the hospital
uh to ER like one morning at three a.m
because they thought I might have blood
clots and I didn't thankfully
and then the second week when I started
to walk it was still like on and off
pain it was very uncertain I then ended
up getting back pain because I was on my
back for so long I couldn't lie on
either side because I had it on both
sides and so then my back was like so I
was waking up at 3am every day for three
weeks because I couldn't sleep anymore
because my back was hurting so I was
walking around at 3am I couldn't sit to
meditate I was doing walking meditations
and he was like how did you not get
depressed during that time and I said to
him that for me
it was the power of my mind and it was a
story it was like I'd lost the strength
in my body for sure
but I kept repeating to myself I'm happy
I'm healthy I'm healing I'm happy I'm
healthy I'm healing and what I was
saying to me it's not that because I
said that I was happy healthy and
healing it's that I had a choice of a
tour which is what you're saying a
belief that I could have either believed
I'm sad I'm hurting and it's all over or
I'm happy I'm healthy and I'm healing
and as just as you said it's not that
that belief or that thought made me
better but it's just that if I didn't
have that thought it would have been way
harder to get through that pain and so I
love that to see that in practice what
you just said for me was huge when I
think about younger Generations if you
grew up watching your favorite people
and you knew they were all friends how
does that change the game now because if
you're seeing your favorite people fight
each other and ballet out for the crown
what are you gonna do with the person
sitting right next to you at school and
I think that's I saw that so much
growing up where I've always wanted to
connect with people regardless of what
we do in this space but you saw so many
people who are coming at it from the
perspective of let's see who does better
let's see who does more and again I love
what you said competition's not a bad
thing let's not give it a bad name but
the idea that we've got to be able to
hold two truths we can compete and still
be friends still be friends it was all
about the addiction to number one is
this this idea and you'll love this
there was a study that I saw that said
because you brought up the Olympics it
sparked my brain
there's a study that I saw that said
people who win bronze are happier than
people who win silver
because the people who came second were
this close to First oh my God yeah but
the person who came third they were
happy they were like we weren't gonna
get first but we got in we got on the
podium and it's that Podium syndrome of
at least we got on but the second the
person in silver
they are mad at themselves yeah because
they didn't get number one yeah and so
that addiction to number one is so
strong impact is always greater than
income there is always more impact you
can make so I know that for me what I'm
trying to do with the work I'm doing is
video was an entryway into a journey of
transformation I wanted people to move
from videos to listen to the podcast to
read the book to come to events to come
to Retreats with me in India like I want
to help people go as far on their inner
Journey as they possibly can that's my
personal mission is if someone just
wants to watch a three minute video and
it makes them feel better that's
beautiful but if someone one day wants
to come with me to India and live the
life I lived and have a deep inward
Journey then I want to be able to
facilitate that I'm still building that
bridge to people's deeper cells yes and
so the first thing that always humbles
me and grounds me is I've got a lot of
work to do there's so much suffering and
pain in the world there is so much
unrest in the world there is so much
trauma in the world so we've got a long
way to go yeah so all the awards and the
views they give you confidence that
you're going in the right direction but
you'll know you're far away from the
destinations that's one thing I think
the second thing that really helps me is
being around still spending time with my
monk teachers who have very different
Vision as to what is valuable in life
yeah because they don't care about they
don't care about material possessions or
money they don't care and so they're not
impressed by that and so to be around
people who don't admire certain things
helps you lose taste for it it's kind of
like when I'm around
we all get into these scenarios in the
world where we think we're trying our
best to help and love other people so I
think majority of people feel like they
give more than they get
and I think anyone who's an empath or
feels like they care for others will
feel I give out so much love but I don't
get as much back
and that's how I felt sometimes in the
ashram now the interesting thing is that
I'd forgotten lesson number one in the
ashram and the first lesson in the
ashram was this is a hospital
there are doctors and patients but
remember the doctors are also patients
and sometimes the patients May teach the
doctors
but remember that we're all in the same
space in this hospital where everyone is
going through a process of purification
so that was very clear the ashram was
not meant to be Heaven it wasn't meant
to be this idyllic place where everyone
was perfectly Zen and calm it was a
place where you had to learn to develop
that even amongst the challenges that
were there just like in reality so I'd
forgotten that and I was going well I'm
giving out lots of love and no one's
giving me any love and it was really
emotional for me because I just felt
like I was investing in people and
helping people and supporting people and
and I'll never forget that conversation
and even till this day it's become one
of those conversations that
stays with me and I remind myself of
regularly hence I put in the book
the monk said to me said
just as there were people that you love
and don't love you back
there are people in your life that are
investing in you and loving you that
you've forgotten about
and it was one of those like
stop moments of just
is that true
and I would encourage everyone who's
listening and watching right now to
really think about that think about that
person you've been chasing whether it's
a friend a potential boyfriend or
girlfriend a potential husband or wife
or whatever it may be your job
and then ask yourself has someone ever
chased you in Life or is someone ever
pursued you in Life or if someone ever
tried to love you in life and you didn't
even give them a time of day
the answer is true I could agree with it
I can completely agree with that there
are people in my life who have done more
for me
than I could even begin to try and do
and that isn't just parents and family
members I'm talking about people
professionally that I just can't repay
and so he spoke about it as a theme
called The Circle of Love that you will
always get the love you give out you
will always get it back or whatever you
give out you will always get it back you
just won't get it back from the same
people you give it to
and that was really fascinating to me
because I also realized that I may have
caused hurt to people and they may not
have hurt me back
but I've received hurt from people that
I never heard
and so it works both ways both with her
and love and when you see on both ends
and that's ultimately karma in a in a
tiny nutshell
it's completely grounding
in saying yeah let me take a real look
at my life
and and where those blind spots are
about who I'm not being grateful to who
I'm missing who I'm not expressing
thanks to it's such a powerful question
that should we admire people who are
wealthy and I think we have to be
careful about what we admire because
what you admire will be what your
actions Aspire towards
so you'll start taking on those actions
correct you start taking actions and
behaviors and decisions towards what you
admire and so I would say that I've
always admired people who had a purpose
that's what I admire deeply when I meet
someone I'd say there's two things that
I admire purpose and humility like if I
meet someone who has purpose they're
willing to sacrifice they're willing to
do whatever it takes they are mission
driven they want to serve the world it's
why I was always a fan of yours from
before we even met and we knew each
other because I was like oh here's a
person who really wants to do good in
the world he's a person who really wants
to give and so I think that's the first
thing I look for and then the second
thing I would deeply admire is someone
who has humility someone who I feel that
they were really doing it from the
goodness of their heart so I think for
me my admiration has always been for
those two things and I don't think I can
tell someone whether what they admire is
right or wrong but I would say that if
you admire something your actions are
going to start dictating your journey in
that direction right and so you have to
be careful what you admire because
that's what you're going to chase right
and so I would say that I like admiring
purpose and humility because I think
they are worthy of a pursuit in Think
Like a monk I call it there there are an
infinite number of seats in the theater
of happiness
so we in our minds have started to
believe that every we think now if
you're booking a cinema theater or a
movie theater there's a finite number of
seats you've got to get tickets to the
Olympics there's a finite number of
seats there's tickets to the uh
Coachella whatever it is it's like
there's a finite number of seats and so
that finite finite finite finite has
been drilled so deeply into us but there
are infinite number of seats and there's
a seat with your name on it in the
theater of happiness and just because
I'm already in there doesn't mean you
can't be in there just because you're in
there doesn't mean I can't be in there
and as soon as you realize that you free
yourself from realizing there is a seat
with your name on it and and all you've
got to do is claim your own City and no
one else can take that seat from you and
when you start living like that you can
collaborate you can grow together you
can build together and you see this as
being the epitome of I was just reading
Bob iger's book and and in there he
talks about how it was and I may get a
few of the names wrong but I think it
was it was Steven Spielberg for sure
it's George Lucas I think it's Quentin
Tarantino he's saying they used to get
together and they would critique each
other's movies before they came out so
to give each other feedback you're
talking about some of the best of all
time like being comfortable showing
their work to their competitors right
now that's the point right like I've
never watched the Quentin Tarantino film
and felt I was watching a Steven
Spielberg film and I've never watched
the Spielberg film thinking I'm watching
a George Lucas film which just shows a
how incredibly creative and talented
they are but also how much they trusted
what they were offering to the game yeah
and that to me is such a powerful
metaphor and I mean it's not even
metaphor it's literal of of how you live
in a there are an infinite number of
seats in the theater of Happiness how
many of you spend a lot of your days
multitasking
okay good
so a lot of us spend our time
multitasking now studies show that only
two percent of us are actually able to
multitask
and when most people hear that they're
like yeah I'm in that two percent that's
me right I'm in that two percent uh
you're probably not I'm not because it's
only two percent of the global
population of the world multitasking is
a myth and I find that as spiritual
activists as conscious change makers as
change agents of the world whatever you
want to call yourself
all of us one of the biggest mistakes
we've seen and this was the quote that I
shared in a thoughtful Martin Luther
King that I've really held close to me
is he said those who love peace
need to learn to organize themselves as
well as those who love war
right those who love peace need to learn
to organize themselves as well as those
who love war I.E people are trying to
build
destruction in the world and
distractions in the world are highly
organized highly focused highly data
oriented highly strategic highly process
driven
we have to be the same and when you
spend time with vision you spend time
with the Mind Valley team you realize
their success is intuitive it is deep it
is full of love but it is also highly
strategic it is also highly focused and
therefore it's effective and so for me
my plea to all of you and to myself is
whatever we're going to do let's get
really strategic
let's bring sincerity and strategy
together
let's bring data and dynamism together
let's bring intuition and insight
together
right let's not let's not look beyond
that and think oh that stuff's going to
work out because I intent my intentions
nice
right your intentions not gonna run a
mile
but it would help you run the marathon
but it's not going to run that mile that
you need to do right now and so for me
intention and action intention and
attention both of them are required and
so my recommendation is whatever your
dream is whatever you inspired by
whatever you think is going to have a
positive impact on the world bring both
to that right don't settle for one or
the other balance is not based on time
it's spent on energy we trying to
balance our life based on how much time
we spend with someone as opposed to how
much energy we give it I explain what I
mean if you said to your boyfriend
girlfriend partner whoever's in your
life your friends and you said I really
want to spend time with you and then you
spend the next two hours watching a show
on Netflix but you were both on your
phones and you didn't talk did you like
that is that what you wanted no you
wanted an exchange of energy you didn't
want an exchange of time so when it
comes to balancing your day ask yourself
where's my energy at what energy do I
need and what energy do I want to give
not have I perfectly managed my time
balance is not equally dividing yourself
it's directing yourself back to where
you want to be we all Express anger
differently and therefore usually our
understanding of anger or when we feel
other people are angry is when they
behave as we do when we're angry we
almost assume that that's how people
Express anger so what I wanted to talk
to you about today is that there are six
key anger types or anger Styles right
it's almost like a personality type but
there are anger Styles and each of them
have a unique internal dialogue a unique
internal conversation that you'll have
with yourself and they all have their
own consequential damage that they cause
in our relationships and damage to
ourselves and finally methods to turn it
around they're all different you can't
apply the same message now how many of
you have ever heard advice to your life
as being calmed down right just calm
down right and in my opinion never in
the history of being told to calm down
has anyone ever calmed down right that's
just never happened no one does that no
one calms down when you tell them to
some people may do so notice that even
the antidote or the cure to anger is
different for different people hence
when you want someone to just switch off
and snap out of it they can't even if
you do hence when you tell people to
count to ten or count back to from 100
they can't do it because they don't
function like that we all function
differently with anger hence even if
you're advising even if you're guiding
people the first thing we have to
acknowledge is that everyone experiences
and expresses anger differently let's
start with
anger style number one
Angus Town number one is what I like to
call explosive right it sounds like a
good song but it's not explosive it's it
may take a lot to push you over the edge
so it takes you time to be pushed over
the edge but when you get there the
Earth shakes and people Run for Cover
right you know who you are if you know
I'm talking about you now why do we do
that I've always been interested since I
studied Behavioral Science I've always
been interested in why we do what we do
so a question I asked yesterday was what
did I study at University I studied
Behavioral Science as a focused topic so
why do we do what we do the truth is the
reason why for those who have an
explosive anger style the reason why we
do that is we've never been taught to
properly deal with irritation so we talk
a lot today in this world about
tolerance and tolerance almost feels
like you're trying to squash all your
anger into a box constantly like you're
trying to get this and squeeze in and
you can't quite shut it if you travel a
lot like me it's like trying to shut a
suitcase and the suitcase just won't fit
and you're trying to pull the zip around
and you're trying to squash this zip
together so you can pull it through but
it doesn't quite work
when we're not taught to be tolerant in
the right way when we're not taught to
deal with regular irritation what
happens is that we absorb or swallow
pain or anger as much as we can until we
can't anymore this is the most common
form of anger we're constantly trying to
suppress we're quantities trying to
squeeze constantly trying to push it
away but at one point it all has to come
out and it explodes erupts like a
volcano hence the term explosive so
whether you are type 1 or you experience
type one here's what happened the result
is that you over amplify the issue that
you argue about because you've boxed it
in for so long you've kept in all these
little irritations so tolerance is not
about just keeping an irritation
tolerance is about acceptance and
letting it go but the problem today is
our tolerance our version of Tolerance
is almost just capturing and keeping
hold and absorbing and swallowing all of
this until we have to take it out so the
way to do this now how to turn this
around the amazing thing is when you
look at Neuroscience right and this is
what I love I'm trying to share with you
evidence-backed signs things that are
propelled by how science talks them and
I hope you're going to press share right
now so we can get lots more people
thinking about anger
the neurological neurological anger
response believe it or not last no more
than two seconds right when you
experience anger in terms of Neurology
in terms of your brain it's only a
release a chemical release of two
seconds right so it actually takes more
now if you knew that
well done to you and if you didn't know
that I mean tell me tell me I mean that
shocked me when I've read that statistic
I was like wow neurologically we only
experience anger for two seconds which
means it takes commitment to carry on
being angry how many of you have ever
felt angry for two or three seconds but
felt actually you know what I'm gonna
play on this for a bit longer so that
the person realizes how angry I am how
many of you have almost acted anger
right we all become method actors where
we pretend to be angry or amplify our
anger just so that people realize how
angry we are so it takes commitment to
stay angry meditation is awesome deep
breathing is awesome taking moments now
but the one thing I wanted to talk about
how to really deal with exclusive
explosive anger at the root explosive
anger comes because we're constantly
suppressing little things that Annoy Us
because we think that we can just let
them go and we think that if we bring up
these little things someone's going to
get really annoyed at us how many of you
worry that if you brought up these
little things that are annoying you it
will really annoy your partner or your
colleague or whatever it is so one of
the best ways to do this is actually to
write it down when we write things down
we have to articulate things better if
you imagine if you had to send a tweet
140 characters the amount of energy that
goes into articulating 140 characters it
takes much more effort than articulating
a thousand four hundred words so what
I'd like you to do is when you're
feeling that moments of Tolerance being
tested or there's agitation or that
frustration it's writing it down and
articulating it in 140 characters about
how you actually feel and then kind of
analyzing that statement and trying to
get all of your feelings out on paper
where you're almost reconciling how you
feel without having to share with that
person I could live with purpose and
happiness so let's go back to the start
told you you had to
had in real success between putting
yourself first or hustling between
finding a purpose or achieving happiness
I couldn't choose just one so I chose
all of them
success is the hustle of finding your
purpose through your passion and to
never sleep on your happiness
now I've tried other people's version of
success and it doesn't work discovering
my passion opened up a world of purpose
where hustling was not sacrificing my
well-being but instead unveiling a world
of happiness
that's the success I chose now what will
you decide I think that a lot of people
are looking for peace what do you say to
those people who are just in search of
peace I'm glad you asked this so the
tagline of my book is called train your
mind for peace and purpose every day wow
I believe that it's something that can
be trained and I believe it's something
that you have to take responsibility for
the world around you is never going to
be fully peaceful ever even if there was
World Peace you would still not have
peace with a little argument with your
partner or a little issue at work like
there's that's never going to disappear
so the desire for everything around you
to be calmed is a Wishful thought that
doesn't have an end whereas the feeling
of wanting to create calm and peace
within is very realistic
and the point is that that piece is
always going to get triggered and I
think that's the mistake we make we're
looking for this perfect consistent
never touched definition of Peace
whereas peace is something you're
constantly training yourself to look for
so what I would say is that people
should try and find the one activity
they have in their day that brings them
peace it could be sitting and having
them wanting tea it could be sitting and
reading from a book they love it could
be having a beautiful conversation their
partner whatever it is just have one
activity a day that brings you peace in
my book obviously I talk about a lot
more than that but to find just
something that brings you peace it could
be a mindset that brings you peace so I
really believe that all stress pressure
or lack of peace comes from your mind
being ahead of your body
or your body being ahead of your mind so
how many times have you been in a
scenario where your mind's like racing
really really fast and your body's like
oh I just want to be in bed right right
everyone been in that situation yeah or
you're in the opposite scenario where
your body is moving really really fast
doing a lot but your mind's like oh I'm
still want to be in bed oh that was me
yesterday right right so we've all
experienced both you get into all this
in your book don't you yes oh I can't
wait to tell you that so the alignment
of the two
is what creates peace let's imagine I
was running late today and I'm stressing
I'm like I haven't thought about this
and I don't know what it's about and
maybe I'm you know all that stuff that
we know that you'd be stress about when
you were running to work and I'm sitting
in the back of a Lifter on Uber or I'm
driving and I turn up to the meeting
because you live in L.A and you can
drive correct so what I would do is I
sit down and I breathe in for the same
count that I breathe out oh yeah so I
breathe in for a count of four and
through the nose out through the nose
out through the mouth and I breathe out
for a count of four now when you breathe
in for the same amount of time as you
breathe out you're aligning your body
and mind why because your mind is
counting one two three four and your
body in unison is breathing in and out
one two three four I think we live in a
world right now where we have such a
responsibility
other people grow up think
think Young Generations that all growing
up right now like the amount of impact
that one word you say one product you
sell everything you do can either wire
that person's trajectory into just
consumerism and materialism or
be doing exactly the same thing and you
could change someone's trajectory to
Passion purpose and living a meaningful
and fulfilling life shareability
[Music]
currency of social media
is less shareable it gets less views it
gets less engagement
the most viewed
upon the most shared content the most
shared content is the content that made
you feel
it's not made you think one of these
things
the number one feedback I can get
is me opening up an email or a DM where
someone's randomly messaged me and it
says you just stopped me from committing
suicide
like that like nothing compares to that
like genuinely no big deal size paycheck
campaign whatever none of that compares
to that feedback like if I read a
message that says that that message
always gets a response I had one of my
teachers that has kept saying to me for
years he goes if you want to move three
steps forward you have to go three steps
deep
and so if I'm not going forward I know
it's because I haven't gone deep so for
me that's a big priority for me and
that's what I try and do and I'm I try
and do that every day but I also believe
in immersive experiences so a lot of us
today we live in this world which is
like 10 minutes a day do it for 10
minutes a day everything will be great
and that is great there's nothing wrong
with that
imagine you spent with a boy or a girl
your partner whoever it was someone that
you just started dating imagine you
spent 10 minutes a day with them
how long would it take you to figure out
whether you wanted to fall in love with
them or not
in time
you spent a weekend
a meditation mindfulness all these
habits are the same the more you immerse
yourself the more you get an experience
that stays with you the more that you
can live with that experience and keep
going back to it for 10 minutes a day
the trifecta on all my videos is I
listen to someone who shares a challenge
with me so if you ever share a challenge
with me you have to be okay with the
fact you may end up as a story in one of
my videos right I'm just throwing it out
there the second thing I try and find is
I try and find a scientific study to
verify what I'm about to say as a
solution and the third thing that I do
is I try and find a piece of wisdom
that's thousands of years old that also
aligns with that so for me that's what
I'm always looking for and that's how I
create my content because that way I can
verify it through modern science it's
it's Timeless wisdom that's been true
for thousands of years and at the same
time it's based on a real challenge that
we're all going through I believe that
Humanity needs a shift in terms of
priority belief systems values if we
want people to live happy fulfilling
meaningful lives purposeful lives and
those to me are my definition of
happiness and success is am I living
with purpose am I living with meaning
and do I feel fulfilled and I think that
the biggest way to shift that is through
the culture that we're most absorbed in
and that's Entertainment culture I
believe that the way we're going to
shift the majority of mindsets in the
world are through entertainment the most
successful people in the world the most
healthy wealthy and wise people in the
world choose education over
entertainment and the most unsuccessful
people in the world healthy unhealthy
unwealthy or unwise are choosing
entertainment over education and I made
it my mission in life as to how do we
use entertainment
the vehicle
for Education how can we start with
entertainment first so let me have a
heart of Education that can really
uplift lives because I don't think we're
going to take everyone away from their
television screens or their Digital
streaming services towards courses books
and all of this incredible stuff that
some of us are involved in how do you
work through judgment so I think this
goes back to the monk training we were
lit one of the biggest mantras we were
trained in as monks was don't judge at
the moment and we would literally repeat
that to ourselves time and time and time
and time again and you'll be shocked to
understand if you keep repeating that to
yourself that thing annoys the hell out
of you because it stops you from judging
but literally the first thing that comes
to my mind when something doesn't go the
way I planned for it to go is don't
judge the moment and it's a simple
Mantra it's been life-changing for me
because so many times we're so quick to
label a situation like we label a
situation as good or bad instantly if we
get some good news we immediately think
this isn't
and then that same amazing news in a few
months could end up being the worst
thing that happened to you oh it's the
other way around will you label a
situation as bad and a few months later
that's the best thing that happened to
you happiness is how you feel about
yourself when you're by yourself because
when you buy yourself no one to validate
you anymore and so when we walk out of
the house we're always like do I look
good in this to someone else
ask yourself do I look good in this
because you can end up wearing something
that you didn't like because someone
else liked it and then at the end of the
night you're like I wish you didn't tell
me to wear that
yeah build that mask for your whole life
career for your whole life imagine you
wore that purpose for your whole life
and at the end of your life you look
back and go wow I just did all of that
because 10 people thought it was amazing
we've all had the story and I'm just
sharing it again to give contacts we've
all had the story of the two wolves or
the two dogs however you want to phrase
and if you haven't I'll tell it now it's
it's a story of how inside of us there
are two dogs two wolves and they're
fighting for Supremacy so inside you one
is the initiator and one is the responde
your whole life you've been feeding and
listening to the initiator so your
initiating wolf is strong powerful bulky
aggressive because it's been fed well
your whole life and your responsive dog
your responsive wolf has not been fed
has not been listened to and so it's
weak and feeble and meek and humble and
doesn't even stand a fight so when they
too come to fight inside of you this
this Wolf's just going to eat that wolf
right up and that's what's happening
right now so for all of us whatever two
wolves you're seeing whether it's your
mind and your intelligence whether it's
your intuition versus what your parents
say whether it's expectations of society
versus your expectations of yourself
like whatever two wolves you have inside
of you the one that wins is the one you
feed and the ones you have been feeding
now if you're at a point where you are
and where I am and where all of us are
in different scenarios of our life where
we're trying to shift and start feeding
the other one it's hard because the
other one's just been fed more it's
stronger it's able to push you it's able
to dictate you and this is where
detachment's okay that Detachment
doesn't mean that you owe nothing
Detachment means that nothing owns you
and most of us have become owned by our
darker walls most of us have become
owned by the self that we don't want so
so that conditioning has been drawn up
the only way to break it is to disrupt
the pattern to really break that it has
to be and this is why I talk to people
about immersive experiences like you
meditating for 10 minutes a day on a
headspace that's wonderful and I
recommend it but that's not gonna shift
this in a drastic way you are going to
have to go and spend a week out in
Joshua Tree with this Shaman you are
going to have to take a break it's
Jerusalem right we were both in love
with Jerusalem like instead of going on
a holiday this year you are going to
have to go on a three-day intensive
transformative Retreat and the reason
why I'm saying all these different
things is they all have different
budgets they're all available in
different countries you don't have to go
to India and live with monks but you
have to do something and it has to be
immersive because when you get immersed
in something then you're giving
something the power to break your
pattern right and I think the challenge
is we're trying to solve it by a little
thing every day which is a good start to
get us going but if you're really
serious about a massive shift in your
life wherever you're seeing that energy
coming from for the right side the
responsive side yeah you need to go
water that you need to go feed it you
need and you need to go give it energy
and that's what I think
we find that and that that's what I
think people struggle they still want to
go on their Beach holiday
they they're like no I can't give that
up I need that or this weekend I still
need to go and do up my house and it's
like well no like just imagine what
would happen if this weekend you just
went on a three-day Retreat that changed
your life like imagine if you just gave
that energy just because there's junk
food there's junk media
and junk media is as addictive as junk
food but it's not great for us this is
my belief if you present people healthy
food but in a way that looks and tastes
like junk food they will switch and
that's what I'm trying to do I'm trying
to create content that looks and tastes
like junk food but isn't and it's real
media and so for me it's like how can we
create that on the platform where people
already are and what you've shown me and
this is my belief in people I believe
people are smarter than we think they
are I believe people are deeper than we
think they are I believe that people are
more beautiful than we think they are
and when you deliver content at that
level for people they respond what we
need is for everyone to tell their story
authentically you don't have to go and
break a boundary you telling your story
authentically and sincerely is breaking
a boundary because there's no one like
you and so when you do that you're
giving power to someone to be them right
when you're more you everyone gets
powered to be more them don't have a
to-do list have a to-do list like who do
you want to be today
because that's where happiness comes
from when you've ticked off everything
on your to-do list but you're really
stressed out are you happy
no you're not because we don't get happy
by doing we get Happy by being and so
the way you have it to be list is like
do I want to be kind today fine I'm
going to be kind in every interaction do
I want to be present today I'm going to
be present in every interaction what are
you going to be that's going to build
happiness satisfaction and contentment
in your life not I'm going to do XYZ if
we're observant of our friends we'll
notice patterns in their posting that
actually can help us take care of them
better sometimes people are less open
with you and they're more open on social
media or if you're smart and you really
care about someone you like to be able
to see from their posts so if I see from
someone's poster they're posting
something depressive or sad every day
don't just like or comment on their
posts pick up the phone and call them up
right it's like actually giving you
information so you're actually learning
about that person or if you're seeing
someone post something happy every day
and then they stop posting dad's giving
you a pattern as well so actually I like
using the tool as a way of reaching out
to people and I think that shows us and
our care as friends is like can we
notice
the patterns in our friends posting or
whatever they're sharing that can
actually help us help them with their
Mental Health
I think as creators we often read a lot
of negative comments how many of you
ever have read negative comments about
yourself right and it's it's not the
most fun thing to read you know
sometimes what we do and we do this as
humans too is we amplify the negative so
like literally everyone here could come
up to you and be like you're amazing I
love what you do and then one person can
come up to and be like you're pretty
average like I hated your last video and
we go home think about that one person
who said that bad thing about us so my
advice is respond to every person that
leaves a positive comment
and don't worry about debating with the
negative people like just you're trying
to convince people that don't have the
right energy for you but one of the
mistakes we make is we don't respond to
the negative or we respond to them but
then we forget about the people who
actually leave really beautiful positive
comments and the thing I love about that
value is when you read those positive
comments that's great for your value
because now you're not looking at the
metric of views or the metric of shares
but you're looking at real impact in
someone's life and ultimately remember
this you know they've been some of the
worst leaders in the world that have had
a lot of followers and there have been
some pretty incredible leaders in the
world who had like seven followers so
that's not necessarily an indication of
how powerful you are who you are and how
amazing you are as a person at all and
and I think it's just important to
remember that that that's not really
what it's about we all know that and and
it's about the impact you're making on
one person's life and in just that one
person can be so much more powerful and
meaningful some of the best strategic
thinkers they see patterns I was
speaking to someone
earlier last week and it was really
funny because I was thinking about you
know in the past our parents were
previous generations were struggling to
earn money they were struggling to get
by they were trying to think of new
ideas that were you know immigrants that
were moving around the world you know so
many challenges and I was thinking to
someone they're just like I can't get to
a thousand followers on Instagram and I
was just like are you kidding me like
literally like that's what we're
worrying about right we're worrying
about how to get a thousand followers
thousand Instagram uh likes all this
kind of stuff when Generations before us
were worrying about stuff that was much
more huge so one of the things we need
to really connect with and recognize is
is our work actually adding value are we
actually trying to add value to people
are we just looking at the result one of
the biggest challenges of strategy is
that we get so fixated on having a
certain outcome that we look at our
process and we don't even know what's
going wrong we're going why are no one
watching my videos why is no one liking
my post why is no one buying my product
well oh is your product made for the
people are you really trying to serve
are you really trying to create
something that people are going to value
or are you actually trying to create
what you feel like creating so it's
finding your passion but your passion
turns into a purpose when you use it to
serve others and that's the key your
passion is great on its own but if you
don't use it to make a difference in the
lives of other people it will always be
undervalued and the biggest part of
strategy is surround yourself by people
who've built that strategy who made that
successful learn from them understand it
and design your strategy the first thing
is premeditation Right strategy
represents planning carry down and
advance advance don't just wing it right
I said in my social media post for this
hope is not a strategy winging it is not
a strategy right it's not going to help
you learn it's not going to help you
grow figuring out how your competitors
Act is a great way of doing it but as
Simon sinek said when he was on my show
um Amante Oswego he was talking about
how he went when he went to a Microsoft
conference they were talking about their
competitors when he went to an Apple
computer about the future if you're
talking about future Trends you're
already ahead right take some time get
some analysis and ideas remember look
for Good Counsel but make sure your
council is strategic Council people who
know what they're talking about that
audience was amazing like
that was incredible it was so much fun I
was you know three hours of sleep
I had a sore throat this morning you
heard me I was whispering and then on
top of that it was my first time back
and it was I'm on such a high like I'm
such a high my wife just messaged me and
she said how are you feeling how are you
doing she knows I left early morning and
I was like I'm just on a high like I
just always feel that way when I'm on
stage get to be with people get off
stage even the meet and greet was just
so many just beautiful humans it was
just so much beautiful energy I feel
like
what we were all starved of for the last
18 months
was a feeling of love
because everyone felt so
everyone felt so empty that they didn't
know where to give and get love from but
I'll tell you right now that the people
that I just met they had a lot of love
to give and there were thousands of them
like you know a couple of thousand
people in there who had a lot of love to
get and it just shows me that no matter
how hard it's been everyone's got love
so so I feel I haven't worked on my
skill set for the last 18 months of
being on stage I feel like you should
never stop working on your strands a
good example is Cristiano Ronaldo I mean
he's 36 years old and for anyone who
watches the Premier League the guy is
just phenomenal if it comes to work
ethic and refining your skill like my
role model is Cristiano Ronaldo I don't
think anyone Works harder than them I
don't think
anyone tries to sacrifice everything
else for the aunt as much as him and so
that's what inspires me that you know
when you do what you love you don't
you're not complacent about it you don't
take it for granted you actually
constantly try and get better at it then
I realized that even though having the
skills was one thing but then having
something you were passionate about to
talk about that's what changed my life
you have to seek the love and the beauty
that you want in what you have now
because that way you're training
yourself to extract meaning right now
which means in the short term if you can
like those Hospital workers we're doing
if you can fill that role with meaning
and your true passion and what's coming
from you then that's going to lead you
to discovering the power of it and I saw
that in my own life when I came back
from being a monk and I worked in the
corporate world I was teaching
meditation and mindfulness and the
things that I talked today
in the corporate world and I remember in
2014 I was invited by one of our
Executives to teach mindfulness to a
thousand of my peers at Twickenham rugby
stadium
and I was speaking in between the CEO
and will Greenwood who won the Rugby
World Cup with England
and and I'm sitting there in the
audience as a complete nobody and
completely around people who are my same
age we all make the same money no one
knows who I am
and there I'm sitting there going how am
I going to share mindfulness but after
doing that experience I realized that
even though my job was digital strategy
and social media Innovation and I was a
consultant I was bringing my passion to
the workplace which actually gave me
confidence that I could do this outside
of the workplace and that's how the two
ideas connect that when you find how you
can apply it to your small world you
then get the confidence and the courage
to take it out and make something real
of it whereas I think a lot of us are
waiting for that break to get into doing
it in reality but we actually haven't
even tested it or experimented on it in
in a small space where we can develop
our
our own confidence and courage around it
I live a high performance productive
efficient purposeful life
I have for quite a few years now what
that means is I am constantly dealing
with also high levels of stress and
monitoring and managing them in in high
doses what that also means is that if if
uncontrolled or if not communicated
effectively there are times when I can
be snappier and more irritated at my
wife because she's the person that I'm
around all the time and what I started
to realize wrongen was I was becoming
someone I didn't want to be because when
it came to the person I love most in
this world who's my wife I was being
irritable I was being Snappy I was I was
releasing my stress not in a angry loud
shouty way that's not who I am but but
even if it was passive aggressive it
could be silent or subtle but it was
still not healthy
and I started to look at that I think
wait a minute if I'm trying to be a good
person if I believe I'm a good person
why am I acting in ways that are not
aligned with myself and I think everyone
can relate to that when you've had the
stress of your day or your boss is
giving you a hard time or the kids
haven't been well behaved today or
whatever it may be and now you and your
partner are the ones sharing all that
stress
and I started to realize a couple of
things the first thing was
managing stress
was as important as managing my
relationship and that's the point you've
just raised you think the challenges in
your relationship chances are the
challenges in how you manage stress when
I've meditated effectively when I've
rested and slept my eight hours seven to
nine hours a day when I've set my
intention I am less likely to be
bothered by the levels of stress and the
second point that I understood was that
I'm not going to be able to perfectly
manage stress all the time because I'm
not perfect I'm human but I can
communicate that to my wife ahead of
time so I'll give an example I'm
traveling for the next couple of weeks
or I'm getting ready to travel and I'm
not with my wife right now she's in
London uh because she has some family uh
someone's not well in her family and
if we were together what I'd be saying
to my wife is
hey I just want you to know the next
couple of weeks is going to be stressful
for me
so if you find me kind of frantically
running around or hectic just know that
I'm going to be experiencing a bit of
stress if you want my undivided
attention just let me know and I'll be
there for you but I just want to preempt
the fact that that I'm I'm gonna be
slightly more stressed out next week so
if I'm not as present if I'm not the
same as I usually am just don't take it
personally it's not about you it's me
and I think saying that and
communicating that ahead of the time
just saves the other person from having
so many other feelings about what's
going on uh and and then you can
actually deal with it better am I right
in saying that over those next few years
you're kind of leaving leading this
almost dual life where you're kind of
deeply pulled into this world of kind of
ancient spirituality and philosophy and
religion and it's totally different way
of looking at the world and totally
different expectations and definitions
of happiness and success but then also
doing University and doing internship at
a bank is that right yeah yeah so I was
interning at Finance Central companies
in London in my summer and then I'd
either spend the rest of the summer or
the Christmas holidays back in the
ashram so I would literally go from
suits wearing suits going to bars eating
at steakhouses
doing the corporate networking thing
trying to make sure I land a job after I
graduate
and then shifting to sleeping on the
floor wearing robes waking up at 4am and
meditating all day and I've always
described that as like my first a B test
or split test right like that that
everyone does now and that split test
has led me to feel I felt fulfilled
every time I came back from the
monastery I just I was just like that's
I just had this amazing experience out
of so many stories to tell I'd have so
many interesting things that happened to
me
and when I was in the work world I was
just trying to impress the person at the
top I was doing whatever it took to make
sure that I stood out I was you know
there was always a bit of like
uncertainty because you don't know
whether the people there are competing
with you or they're your colleagues like
it's this awkward environment and I
didn't feel fulfilled and so for me it
was a very natural process of
elimination of going well how do I feel
and I think that's one of the reasons
why I recommend that everyone
experiments so much and you don't have
to go and spend a couple of weeks in an
ashram in India but if you can
experiment on a potential passion over
the weekend or a potential hobby over a
three-day Retreat or something that you
find interesting over an online course
like there are just so many resources
out there that help you experiment
without much cost uh not just
financially but in time and energy
and when you do that you get this sense
of whether something works or not so if
I'd never worked in a financial company
I would never have known whether that
was good or bad and if I'd never gone to
the monastery I would never have known I
can only think so much in my head and I
think so much of us today we're trying
to figure things out in our mind like we
think oh yeah I could just mentally
figure out what my passion is or what I
should do or how I should live my life
and I actually don't think you can
because
you only know through the lived
experience because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for some amazing Lewis Howes
inspiration check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there from then it was just finding the
right situ environment the right coaches
the right training to become the best
athlete I could be to get to that dream
then when that was over I knew I still
wanted to inspire people from as a kid I
wanted to make people feel better